I haven't really messed up the settings for this, but I'm having a stroke.
I think that's the timestamp for the movie.
Good morning, good evening, and good afternoon to all the Reflings from all across the world.
I can hear myself. Stop talking a moment. Stop it.
Closing all my tabs and...
Oh right, I've closed everything off.
Right.
No.
You may be sent yourself.
Strongly!
Wait, my mic is delayed?
Is my mic delayed?
I think...
I think my microphone is delayed as shit right now.
I just...
No?
It's a...
Hmm.
Could you raise the gain?
Out of sync a bit?
Yeah, I see that too, what the fuck?
Why, Mr. SMB, what's wrong with you today?
You're on the correct sentence.
Of course, like, oh my god, Mercy couldn't have spoke true words when she said,
everything you do, you can change not a single thing from the last thing you did yesterday.
And the ting's having a stroke.
And all the good time.
I don't really want to reset it because it's got filters on it.
I've had fucksack!
Yeah, the model's looking a bit odd.
Leave my out of sync model alone, okay?
The pilot...
The pilot and the mecha aren't cooperating, okay?
I can't believe it.
Testing.
What, what the fuck?
The SMB's delayed by, like, a second.
I don't want to delete it because I don't know what filters are on it.
Wait, I do.
I've got de-noise and gain on it, and I'll need a read.
How much gain?
Oh, for fuck's sake.
Testing.
Why are you delayed?
You're stressing me out.
Why?
I'm literally doing ventriloquism.
I'm watching it be so delayed in 4K.
What the heck?
Can you forgive me?
Can you forgive me if we...
Because to be honest, I'm going to be pretty quiet whilst we're watching the movie anyway.
Hi, good morning. I'm so sorry.
Right, you're just going to have to forgive me.
I think it might be clashing with everything I've got with the movie set up.
That's my only guess.
It's my only guess.
I'm not smart enough for this.
Let's see.
I mean, technically watch the movie.
Yeah, if you guys can forgive me practicing my ventriloquistic sensibilities,
then I'm just going to pretend like I'm not a second out of sync for some reason,
because SMB's delayed for a second.
Today, we are playing Grinscape.
I have a sugar ton of wine to level up.
I don't even know what world I'm in.
Probably not in a free world, so we can all hang out.
380 blaze it, please.
Here you go.
Switch world, please.
So me and the reflins can hang out.
You're so cute as a vent.
Can you raise the gain?
Of end game or me?
End game.
Assume you mean end game forever.
Hi.
Okay, my reflins are here.
Or do you mean the microphone?
Because the microphone was cool, huh?
Oh, wait, hold on.
I'm a fucking idiot.
How's that input?
Oh, that's...
Sorry, I'm bursting your eardrums.
How's that for input?
Oh my god, my gain was set to so low.
Oh, oh no.
My gain on the focus rate was...
I'm so sorry.
Sorry.
That's cut out.
No, sorry.
I just realized all I had to do was turn the knob.
You wouldn't believe how many problems in life
can be fixed by turning the knob.
Oh no, this can't be.
Right.
Right, right, right, right, right, right.
Let's get a cheeky update on everything
that's happened since I last saw you
in Balatro yesterday, okay?
Hear ye, hear ye.
For those of you who are a member
and wrote a membership script with me,
that audio is now live on Patreon.
You can hear...
So you can literally watch the script
being made in an hour,
and then you can listen to how...
It took an hour to write the damn thing,
took an hour to edit the damn thing,
and it came out to less than 15 minutes.
Arrest my case.
It literally is redonkulous
how long it takes to make these kind of things.
But yes, that audio is now out on Patreon.
So all four are technically five in my case
because I did have a demo reel to test my voice
because I was very confident.
So I technically have five audios on Patreon as well.
It looks like your model's behind the audio,
which means your model...
No, the model's not out of sync.
The SMB's out of sync.
This fucking thing is delayed.
I can see it not being in sync with me right now.
It's the SMB.
It's not the model.
The model's in sync.
And I don't know how to put a one-second delay
on the model input, so I can't do it.
It's not V2B Studio.
It's fine.
We're gonna watch John Wick.
It's not gonna be that bad.
However, however, I just don't open my model's mouth at all.
And then it's less frustrating for everyone watching.
Yeah, you didn't think about that, did you?
There we go.
Okay, next update.
This is fucking awful.
Next update.
My 2000 celebration subscription and video is out,
where I clean your ears.
The video almost got limited ads
because of my opening sentence.
This is the silent mouth technique, honestly.
So, the...
Aventure?
I can't believe Johnny got a mouth wipe shot, honestly.
But it's the same when you get done for your teeth.
My 2000 celebration is out.
The next audio, if you're interested in ASMR or audios,
is a collaboration with a wolf.
That's your hint, and that's all you're gonna get.
Teeth clenching ASMR, let's go.
Literally, yay, it doesn't look like I'm out of sync
because my lips aren't moving at all.
Um...
The viewer isn't being the eventual because of my accusations.
Oh, no, no, I don't know why it's not...
I don't know why it's delayed.
Anyway, I just want to preference this stream by saying
I'm gonna give up my all to watch all four John Wick's with you,
even though there's apparently a fifth one,
which defeats the purpose of trying to finish a series together.
Um, I just want to say the likelihood of tomorrow's
runescape endurance stream being swapped for something else
is astronomically high, okay?
I'm back to feeling sick, I'm back to feeling stressed,
I am back to being constipated,
and it happens right before the endurance stream.
So don't think I'm not going on to you, body.
I know exactly what you're doing.
My body is rejecting endurance streams,
but I'm saying no, okay?
Aren't you supposed to practice mental fortitude or whatever?
Well, mental fortitude, these wines in Edgeville,
I'm gonna mental fortitude so hard all over these wines.
Um...
So I'm not really sure what's going on with my body.
But my dad is coming over very soon.
So don't be shocked when you see streams are like
no more than four hours a day.
Like, I'm having to break up cameo in two streams,
which is crazy, because I can do it in one.
I can do it in one.
And like, Viva Pignata's getting broken up into two streams,
like all this kind of stuff.
I had to delay Shadow of Mordor.
Um...
Stress does wild things.
Literally, why the fuck does my stress manifest
that it clogs me full of shit?
Like, I'm sorry to be nasty with the details.
But why does mine go...
Oh...
Right, we're a bit stressed, right?
Mmm...
Okay, enema, enema, give them an enema.
Literally, like, why does mine have to go that way?
Why can't I just be the, oh, I'm exhausted kind?
Like, yeah, I'm a wee bit tired right now.
I guess, yeah.
And I'm not sleeping properly.
Like, yeah, I guess.
But, oh my God, don't be so selfish.
Honestly, did you guys, like, man,
you were short as well about, uh,
not one in a VTuber agency?
I will put the movie on in a second.
Uh, A.C. picked a great time to read.
Oh, please tell me you didn't, A.C.
Snowberries, I'm so sorry.
Hi, A.C. and Snowberry berries.
Um...
I'm so sorry if you caught the tail end of that conversation.
Hopefully not.
Well, I'm currently having to be a ventriloquist
because my, uh, microphone is broken.
We're about to enjoy John Wick together,
so if you want to join in, you most certainly can.
There's a timestamp as well as you'll be able to see on screen
what we're doing, okay?
Uh, I just need to make sure...
you guys can also hear...
Snowberries? Snowberries?
Snowberries?
What? Would you still love A.C. if she was Southern?
Well, how do y'all Snowberries?
Oh, gee, sons, what are you talking about?
What do you mean we can't get the hand-jerking off Booth?
Yeah, that's right. I saw that tweet, A.C.
I saw what happened.
Oh, my little old, my old, gee, sons,
you guys are such perverts.
Yee-haw!
Yeah, we just all love A.C. if she was...
Oh, I'm just putting all the wings in.
Southern A.C. can't hurt you, she's not real.
Southern A.C.
That's right, old, gee, sons.
The other management's a man.
Whoa, wait, wait, wait.
So, A.C. is not allowed to jerk off station,
but I'm allowed the ASMR booth,
where I just straight up R-word reflins, right?
Something's not going on.
Something's not right.
I'm calling out injustice when I see it.
Something's not...
Something's not on.
Right, I'm gonna hit play on the movie
because I've got a cup of tea.
I love all our daughters regardless.
Okay, understood.
We'll hire a Southern A.F. for a Gen 2.
Okay.
We'd love A.C. no matter what.
Alabama A.C.?
You want Alabama A.C.?
We got Alabama at home.
In Canada, in particular...
Well, she's not in Canada right now, she's on holiday,
but yeah, we got Canada at home.
We got Alabama at home.
Her name's Emmy.
Strongly paid-off management.
Probably the physical contact aspect.
Yee-hee.
Can we get a Mongolia?
Wow, and we are not getting a throat singer
for Gen 2.
Absolutely not.
Could you imagine?
I swear to God.
Actually, you know how I've said all this stuff out loud?
What do you think the odds are?
There'll be one little shitposting girl
that's gonna tickle me f-
that's gonna tickle me ivories
and make me laugh by coming out with
doing Mongolian throat singing.
What do you think the odds are of that?
I would be...
I'd be very shocked.
But I feel like there's one that's shitposting
enough to do that.
You're telling me there's not one girl
shitposting enough to be like...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's my impression.
10% chance.
AC just wants to do ASMR to another part of the body.
Oh, yeah, you want pee-pee tingles?
I'd be glad to tell you because I'm boss.
For coming to visit me.
Oh, gee, souls, I'm gonna tingle you myself.
I'm gonna tingle you right here.
That's right.
Don't even need your ears for tingling.
Okay, shall we start with John Wick?
Right, are we ready?
Is everyone got John Wick open?
That's a lot to unpack.
Please don't listen to my crazy rambles.
Right, and before there's like eight slime girls
that apply to be in Gen 2,
but in their condition is I'm not gonna be
if I'm not slime.
Get your snacks.
Is it?
I've got one hour, 41 minutes and 13 seconds.
Everyone ready?
Three, two, one, go!
Fuck, I messed it up.
I'm sorry, I was gonna do the fucking ghost thing,
but then I fucked it up.
There you go.
It's blinding me.
Okay, so basically I'm gonna...
We're gonna enjoy the movie together.
Can you guys?
You guys can't hear the movie.
They're not be able to.
I'm gonna be nervous.
Oh my god, we're doing roller coaster,
a role play, Thunder Road.
Wow, that was...
You need to update that so badly.
I'm not being funny.
When was that made?
I feel like I could do better in any of these.
Right.
I've got scrawny the only snack I need.
Thank you, Rolly Legend.
And Brian.
I'm so out of sync.
Okay, you can't hear it good.
Oh my god, it...
Oh!
See, that's sometimes when you get your driver's license
at like 16 or something.
Oh!
I take it back.
Hold on, let me turn the game sound.
Are we not?
Is this the end of the movie?
Hold on a minute.
Am I on the wrong movie?
Oh, they're kissing.
They're kissing.
It's been many a year.
What the fuck?
I don't remember this.
Fuckin' Elements in a mansion!
Oh my god, he's a 1%.
Get him!
No, I'm just kidding.
That's not what 1% looks like.
I assure you.
Eww!
I was the drip from the coffee cup.
That wasn't correct.
Oh, that's actually really sad.
What the fuck?
POV me.
We were nervous away for a year, Kirkin.
Oh no!
She had a brain aneurysm!
No!
Fuck!
That shit will strike.
Sorry, I might...
Holy shit, this is why we can't watch up
before anyone requests up.
No, I will start crying.
I don't want to cry.
Hold on a minute.
Oh my god.
Bro, am I going to start crying?
What the fuck?
Why is this movie so sad?
It's supposed to be about guns and pew pew!
What the fuck?
I'm like literally tearing up.
Do you mind video game movie?
Holy crap.
No, for fuck's sake!
There's still short scenes.
And don't worry, it gets worse.
Stop.
Am I allowed to cry?
I'm like crying.
But it's okay.
I'll smile in a minute when these scenes go over
and then we can talk about the pistols
and stuff that they use,
because I like the guns.
They always use MPKs.
I don't know, I don't know.
I don't know.
I can't take the guns.
They always use MP5 Kifs and movies
for some reason.
Oh,
Who picked this fucking movie?
It's been like 10 seconds.
Oh yeah, pys, it's the green Goblin!
Oh.
Oh, sorry.
Oh my god, I'm actually waping away my tears. I can't handle this shit.
Ha ha!
Oh.
I can't drink my tea. Now my throat's closed up.
I don't know if you get it when you get teary, your throat closes up.
I can't freaking drink my tea.
No, wait, this is even sadder because didn't this happen to him in real life?
And he never remarried or dated anyone else?
Ah, where the fuck did I pick this? I'm in shambles right now.
I'm snot coming over now.
Oh.
I can't even handle this.
I'm like laughing but...
Oh, I don't remember this phone being so sad.
I just need to drink my tea before it gets cold.
Oh.
Oh my god, what is it?
It better be a breather. It's good and not bad.
What breed is it? If I...
It better not be a pug.
Oh, no.
No!
Oh, wait, what?
What is that? I don't know. I don't know what kind of dog that is.
Oh.
You'll feel better once the killing starts, unironically, yes.
Okay, I'm gonna start telling you about the Makarov and then the invention of the M7-11.
And the utilities of the AK-47, why it's the most popular assault rifle crafted and created.
Oh, hi, poppers.
Oh, hi, sweet thing. Oh, it's so tiny.
Oh my god. Wait, the fact that she knew that he would need something to love on.
No, I can't fucking...
Daisy, no!
This is even worse than you could make it.
Not perfect. It's called...
Absolute shambles.
Who picked this?
Fucks sake, please tell me two isn't like this either. I can't even handle it.
Oh, we popper. No, the popper goes on the bed, you daffodil. Sorry, I don't know.
Yeah, let it on the bed right now. No!
Exactly, that's what I thought. Oh, it's so tiny and wee.
Oh.
Happily ever after fans and shambles at this movie.
Right, I'm gonna try and drink my tea without choking on it and he's stop crying.
Oh, it's like waking in a mop and stuff. Oh, he says, don't...
Daisy goes, don't rot in bed.
Oh.
Well, okay, my tea's called anger-resuming natural emotions reinstating.
Oh, it's got a wee collar and everything.
Oh, he's not got our dog food yet. Yeah. Oh my god, this movie's so real though.
Oh, look at our ee. Look at our wee floppy ears around the bowl. Oh. Sweet.
Oh my god, what a smart puppy for a film crew, honestly.
She's like, I know my spot, I'm getting my treat, I'm gonna go right here. Oh, you're so smart.
Oh, transformers. I'm fucking with you.
Filling up that gas. She said, hey, mama, let me get you a number.
They really said, put the most freaking... Obliette.
Sorry, but Russians are as they've shown us as a bad guy. It's either Chinese or Russian.
Wait, he got his willy chopped off in Game of Thrones.
See you on Greyjoy.
Not for sale. She, ooh, the girl's she, the car's a she. My little puppy.
That guy has 83 in the 86. Close enough. Same number, honestly. They both start with an eight.
Wait, is the young Greyjoy actually a previous speaker or did they just know the lines?
You'll see the Italians in a second, don't worry. Oh, okay. Right, 86 cooking.
Wait, is the puppy in the car when he's going this fast? That thing's sweet,
ears are going to be flapping in the wind.
No, look at the pup.
The truck's almost kissed.
He was using the driving as an emotional outlet for his emotions.
Hi Daisy. No, yes, finally. Dogs belong on the bed. They're so cute and they want to be a part
of the family and they want to be part of the pack. You're supposed to let dogs sleep on the bed for
you because if you don't, it means they're not a part of your pack and it hurts their feelings.
That's right, animals actually have feelings.
Hi Daisy, weezy. Oh, bleat.
Oh, fuck.
I see you.
Brrrr.
Over this?
Over 69 mustang?
Holy shit.
No.
That's so sad.
What the fuck?
Did the fuck put this shit on?
No, don't touch her.
I hate it here.
Oh, what the fuck?
I can't even do that.
I can't even do that for them.
Those are such precious wee things.
No, for fuck's sake, don't call her next to her necklace.
I can't even handle this spell.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Bro.
I'm needing cuddles off your reflins after this one.
What the fuck?
I don't remember any of that, I just remember the guns.
And then in the second movie there's like a sauna scene with cool light in it.
That's all I remember.
I don't remember any of this sad shit.
I would have picked this if I knew how sad it was.
I just make my wings like a good little RuneScape player.
Hey wait, my cat.
Did I read that right?
My cat's son stole the car?
We go?
Okay, at least that guy in the suit seems to actually have some tact.
Oh my god, it is my cat.
Sad parts over our body, hope so.
Take that drink.
Shit, it's on the house.
Oh my god, it's that GT map and Grand Theft Auto IV.
And that little underbridge near the taxi depot.
Actually we should play GT4.
Oblivious.
Ow.
Holy shit.
He's not happy.
Oh my god, I have tears on my blanket.
I can feel them.
Congrats.
He's got other business to attend to.
Theon's been summoned by my cat.
He's gonna go around.
You know shit is real when it's just a singular O, honestly though.
Oh pardon.
Sit down son.
Is he about to get glassed?
No.
Oh.
He's not here.
Per Theon, he always gets beaten up in his roles, honestly.
They're like, oh you're perfect for beating up.
And you're hired.
He's got a punchable face.
Shit.
Holy fuck.
Baba Yaga!
I forgot they called him the boogie man.
Phew.
Oh my god.
A hag witch, eater of men.
Okay, Baba Yaga for Gen 2 confirmed.
And yes.
Here a dead man walking.
Holy shit.
He does say Gigi literally.
He said, oh fuck he's about to bake him.
Oh shit.
He tried it's ogre for his son.
I just got tattoos for this fortune.
Fortuna.
I don't know what his back tattoos said.
Enough goes hard when he didn't say a word.
Oh.
What's happening?
He's got home advantage.
There's the layout.
No his balls.
Actually yes his balls.
Yes everything, they deserve it.
Oh my god that would be terrifying.
We don't want to hurt civilians.
One.
Don't get him involved, it's a messy clean up.
He's in on it?
Police interaction to be honest.
It's like the idea of an underworld currency that the people don't know about.
Oh clean clean clean.
Sorry waste disposals in the background.
Okay okay waste disposal.
I was like 8k 47 time?
No no cleaners cleaners.
They're just in gimp suits, it's fine it's fine.
They just like being in gimp suits.
What is harem?
Ah.
I swear that was literally me in the bag for real for real.
Your cat also talks Russian?
I know I have such a talented little cat honestly.
Thank you well.
I just say thank you in Russian, I don't know.
You know I'm somewhat of a refling myself stop, that's such a good motto for us.
Oh my god my eyes are all puffy from greeting.
Is that Marlon Manson?
A big nice.
The food fighters.
Oh right what can we identify?
What's going up first?
Can we identify any of the guns?
We have sniper rifle.
Oh I'm shit with snipers.
Fuck.
Bindalk Saints.
Is that drip for?
Oh it's that skinny building in New York.
At third mate it looks pretty badass.
Reflings you didn't tell me you looked so cool.
Oh no.
Wait a minute I'm getting a memory.
Lance?
Who's Lance?
The gentleman behind the desk?
The concierge?
Oh.
No I can't handle it.
I'm not going to cry.
I'll be big.
I'm a big girl okay.
I'm not going to cry.
You get back in their tear.
I feel like a form of fucking Rocky Horror picture show up in here.
What's going on?
What?
Jonathan.
Two down to the bone after dog died.
Interesting choice of words Winston.
Hey Winnie.
Oh my god is Winnie the Pooh's name Winston the Pooh?
Haha.
It's not business it's personal.
Ooh is that how we skirt the rules?
Don't kiss me you succubus.
You.
Oh he's so fucking humble.
I'm going to start green again stop it.
Hey.
That's me in the Google page.
I don't even know how Google dance and work ends.
I just know it's called Google dance.
Again bullet proofed up.
You met Keanu Reeves?
A promotion?
I see is literally DJing right now.
I knew she worked at a nightclub before fucking John Wick nightclub.
Oh shit wait.
Right stop memin something big's about to happen stop memin.
It's me look I got a part in the show.
That's not me that part isn't me.
I'm that tall I'm really in that tall I'm tiny.
See that can't be me because that model had 10 toenails my apologies.
Theon.
Before she was AC she was the DJ at the continental.
She recognizes them.
Whoa.
He is scared he's pretending.
I'm having a good time I cried my eyes out.
I like when they give a chance for someone who isn't involved in the business to get out.
I can't wait for the fifth movie.
I don't even know what three or four consists of I think I've seen two but I thought this scene was in two but I think I'm mistaken.
No.
Whoa.
Hell hath no fury like a man scorned like a husband scorned.
No no spoilers for the future movies please because I don't know.
Whoa.
Shit.
Stealth mission failed but we got close.
Fuck.
Fuck we missed.
Fucking AC is good at this holy shit.
I suppose because of how loud clubs are there is a possibility you wouldn't hear the bullets.
Wow.
You know if you ignore all the death the club is banging.
They have no in the background AC and strongy DJ collab honestly I'd be so down.
Fuck.
No civilians remember no civilians.
I didn't know we're in Glasgow.
Go again go again.
I'm pretty sure you can get internal damage even with a bullet per vest on.
So if you guys are like oh get up John get up no like that shit is impactful as fuck.
This club's still banging I'm glad they left the music on AC is really dedicated she said
I paid for my shift I don't care what happens.
No no no no no.
I would be so winded a kid you're not.
I would be me down and out not gonna lie.
True DG let's nothing stop their set.
Oh.
You'll make you swallow them words and choke.
Just like I'll make you swallow them.
Oh we're so fucked up.
Do they have health kits at the continental?
You have a medic?
Medic please.
Thank you.
All the pain.
Oh that was a nasty gas.
That takes time to heal.
Oh the wee ice pack on his shoulders adorable.
I've never seen those.
Bourbon is alcohol that much of a pain suppressor?
This cannot be true.
Have you been stabbed?
I think I'd rather reach for a boot profan over a wee cheeky vodka.
A nasty gas.
Oh you want to see my nasty gas.
You're making it too easy.
If you're drinking off I guess if you get bit faced.
Oh.
No.
Let this poor man rest please give him 24 hours at least.
My boss dinner's night my boss please let me keep him.
Wait.
That was a warning.
Green Goblin's still friendly?
Can I say something really bad?
I like how the only way that they can go hand in hand is when he's severely damaged.
She's only equal when he's 70% dead.
Reflins you can't say that.
I can't get a clear shot.
Fucking hell she like doing maneuvers on him and stuff.
I can't even imagine the pain.
Fuck you can't see the shot at all.
Oh he's going to finish the job.
Oh you made a mistake lady.
Leave my cat out of this.
Oh color me surprised.
You're just...
Oh.
No.
Why don't we convo?
Fuck I hope they managed to close up his body.
He just got the damn stitches in place.
Yeah the director did a great job.
I kind of keep coming back to the dead in the lobby.
I like his voice.
Can I get you some bourbon?
I can't say it though I don't know how to do it but...
Oh!
You shot a holy man.
Oh he's one of them.
He really put the holes in the holy man.
And you think he won't?
Wait what gun is that?
M16?
It's not ACOG.
M4.
I was going to say M16 didn't quite look great.
I blew all the fuck.
He just helped the economy.
We love casting spells.
Shadow Wizard Money Gang.
We love burning money.
John is a refling.
He understands.
Blackrock headquarters.
There you go free mustache wax.
No.
No, no, no.
Oh come on.
Why are we seeing Pina?
I'm helping.
I'm putting down cover fire.
I'd get over there too.
I'm not going to pretend.
He goes for headshots.
Oh that was actually kind of smart.
I wouldn't have thought that myself.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I think we've been captured.
Come on, no, I don't like the look of this.
We're hazy as well.
I don't know, I feel like people change.
Just one comment Vigo, sorry to interrupt.
This is a battle rank.
With love.
We ain't doing the, this person died because it was in God's plan.
She was my wife.
She died because it was in God's plan.
Oh, I'm 87 let's go.
Let's go John Wick for some level 87 and King.
Oh fuck, oh fuck, oh fuck.
Oh shit.
He's a Baba Yaggle, right?
Man's tied up and still manages to, he was so pleased with himself.
See the way he licked his finger there, like yeah, yeah, I did a good job there.
Whoa, I don't recognize the shotgun.
What's going on?
Uh-uh-uh.
Oh, he's him.
Is that one of the, I don't recognize it.
Oh, he's already in.
He doesn't like being kept up in the safe house.
That actor is so good, I don't know how my cat is so good at acting.
Breh.
Can't believe I adopted a mafia cat, it all makes sense now.
It wasn't a hoarder cat's home.
I don't know how my cat is so good at acting.
A car.
It looks like the same as the other one.
It's another one!
Wait, am I being pepega?
Is that his car?
Am I being dumb and it's not the same car?
I can't tell the difference between cars.
No, it's the new one.
Okay, my apologies, my apologies.
An ally.
I thought he said something else there and I was like, oh, in this kind of movie?
Oh, please, give her a rest, woman.
Knock, knock, knock, knock, knock.
Oh.
No!
No.
Oh, come on!
Our only fucking friend?
No!
Oh, no.
No, no.
It's...
Oh, you're fucking done at no.
You've been a bad kitty.
Yeah, you need to get out of the country fast because this man's on you.
No!
Are we gonna walk in on his body?
No, no, no.
I'm crying again. Why do I cry so much? It's supposed to be like an action game.
Why? Every friend and ally he makes.
Why can't this man have anything?
You broke the rules.
If they were all in a diagonal, point at each other?
Anyone? Anyone? If they were all in a diagonal, point at each other?
Uh, no question mark.
I'm pretty sure you can get a double kill with one bullet.
With friends like these.
With friends like these. Come on, we've still got friends in the city.
With friends like these. Come on.
We can do it, we can do it, we can do it, we can get there.
Aw.
The contrast from earlier film where it was like almost cathartic for him to be driving the car?
I mean, I guess it still is.
Hotel bro's coming clutch.
Oh, he's got his V.
He's paid his road tax. I saw that in the front of the car. It had the V paper. He's paid his road tax, lads.
Oh, he's not half him.
He said get off the road.
What is it called when a police car does a tactical takedown?
Like that, that, that, that, that.
A pit manoeuvre.
Oh my God, his senses.
It's always an oozy with a Russian.
There'd be higher pitch.
Baba Yaga.
He's fucking around, he knows he's dead.
Oh wait, we see the Matrix guy?
Ah.
Get the gun, get the gun. Pistole, pistole.
Oh, and there's Bill Perf of course there is.
Get out, out, out, out. Yes.
Oh, it wasn't water.
Holy shit, the thunderclap of the car. I know it's raining.
No, come on, aim.
Manoeil Manoe?
Ah fuck that, I'm sorry, you're getting popped.
No.
He's like had so many drinks in his system.
Now you want to talk, now you want to talk.
I'm fucking cheating.
No.
Ah fuck, we just took organ damage though.
Please be the kidney, we have to.
Oh my God.
Is he gonna bleed out, did he get an artery on my cat?
Oh my God. He did.
Oh my God.
We did it.
He's not done? He did it, John, it's all good.
Where are you? What more business does he have?
Fuck, he can't make it to the con and then offer heals, can he?
Okay, med supply, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, go, go, stuff the wind, stuff the wind.
Pack it in, pack it in.
Oh that's gonna stink.
Oh yeah, oh my God.
We don't mean to stress you out little buddies, it's okay.
We're just visiting, we needed the med supplies.
We're going again? No. Why is this movie so sad?
No. Oh I can't fucking handle this movie, he's going again.
Even though he was so heartbroken and that's the scene where she passed away under the fucking Brooklyn bridge.
No, he has enough love in his heart to keep going.
Okay, what the fuck, these are supposed to be PMP movies.
Okay, what the fuck? Why would you read this?
Oh my God, he has enough love in his heart to keep going.
And he got a new popper.
I don't even know if I'm avoidable, what the fuck?
Okay.
Alright, hold on, if I've done this, if I've set it up right.
Is there any secret scenes in these movies? No, it's just credits.
Alright, I'll let the main credit roll. Oh my God, he has enough love in his heart to go again.
The badass music play and he looks away stronty and absolutely shambles.
Honestly.
Are you squirming me right now?
Sorry, I don't mean to make you greet at work, thank you fully legend for the tip.
Bruh, what the fuck, I don't remember any of the sad parts.
I just remember being like, haha, cool guns, okay, let's watch John Wick.
Don't I fucking regret it? Well, I don't regret it because it was a bloody good movie, but oh my God.
Right, if I've done this right.
Oh shit, okay. Does it see chapter 2 now?
Okay, hold on, wait, I need to pause so it's at the start. Does it see 2 on my thing if I've set this up right?
Which along with the t- yeah, so the movie, there shouldn't be a timestamp, but it doesn't see what the movie is?
Or does it only see what the movie is when I click play again?
Oh, I cannae handle this.
We're also watching, does it say John Wick too? Because I'm smart John Wick.
One piss. Shit, I never did that in time, hold on.
Can I change it?
I'm, hold on, it should be text, text, text, text, text, text, where's text?
Show me the text foil, where's the text file? Sorry, there's like tons of files.
Okay, hold on.
We're watching John Wick too. Okay, yeah, sorry, I don't know why I thought that was going to happen.
Take a breather? Okay, I'll take a moment. I'm going to get, I think I'll get some food.
I'm going to make another cup of tea.
That movie? Oh my gosh, that emotional turmoil in that movie.
What the heck? I don't, I think I'm such a cry baby which doesn't help at all.
Cause like, anything, like, I'm fucking crying just thinking about poor wee John.
But like, he had this happily ever after. I got yanked from him.
I got a puppy that gave him condolence. I got yanked from him.
And then he had enough love in his heart to get another puppy.
It is so sad.
Thank you Dim's doodam for the tip.
Ah, oh my god, it's a picture of a dog. I can see the tip has got a dog in it.
Literally, I can't watch any cry baby films.
Literally, this is supposed to be an action film and I'm greeting my solo.
You cried the entire movie, honestly.
I can't handle any like, things that.
So before anyone says, oh, strongy, watch up.
No, we are not watching up. I will be distraught the entire film, okay?
Ah, right, if I go get some food and a cup of tea, at least my throat won't be as closed up, okay?
Dogs are kind of a cheat code to the tear duct.
Actually, anything with like pets or like the happily ever after gets taken away.
I can't handle it. It's so sad.
But like, I'm okay. Like, I know I'm greeting my eyes out right now, but I'm okay.
I promise I'm okay.
Oh, it's just going fucking there.
Oh, right, I'm fine. I'm fine.
He got a new puppy. Life is good.
I'm sorry if I'm making anyone upset by my crying.
The feature was crying makes everyone unanimously upset. Sorry.
Oh, right, I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm fine.
It's an action movie.
Didn't we not appreciate all the guns? Oh my God.
And did you see the way they reloaded and there wasn't too many bullets in the magazines
that didn't make any sense, like some other movies, like literally every other movie that has like infinite ammo, infinite clips.
So I do appreciate the detail that went into this film.
I have to admit, they casted Big Kenny Reeves perfectly.
I can't believe they casted Makat as the freaking mafia boss.
Like, sorry, but Makat Vigo, his backstory was that he came from a hoarder home.
It wrong. He came from the Russian mafia and he has to now hide out.
He's now a fugitive in my house as I feed him nibbles and give him those lucky lick pouches that I like.
Oh my God. But that's like such a good movie.
I forgot, I completely repressed.
The only part I remembered was the bath house scene because of the light and was like nice neon.
I literally had forgotten all the other aspects of the movie.
So I don't, I am now unsure if I've actually seen John Wick 2.
I know for a fact I haven't seen 3 and 4. I didn't know they existed.
I thought I had seen 2, but I only remembered the bath house and that was in 1.
So I have a sneak in suspicion. I've actually not seen 2, 3 or 4.
So I have no idea what I'm going up against.
Who the new enemy is.
As for wines, yep, we're whining away.
I briefly got 95 cooking.
So I was at 94. Why are you guys ahead of me?
You've been playing offline without me, huh?
Bath house had some but literally I got hired, but then they, I went to a casting,
but then they denied me because I only have 9 toenails and they were like,
oh we can't cater to that.
We can't cater to that. That's disgusting.
I'm like, oh okay I guess.
Like I tried, I tried.
Sorry, I did some off-screen. No, you're not in trouble. I'm teasing.
Anyone's welcome to level up off-screen.
1 was, number 1 was 2014. 2 was 2017.
Oh, I don't, um, I, because of that bath scene in the colour scheme,
I thought that was in 2, but it wasn't.
So I actually don't know what's up ahead, I don't think.
Nothin' yell, pedicure.
Actually.
Ah, astronomy's who says the continental confirmed.
Literally, a new business, eh, we VEGO, no havin' it.
Oh, right.
And I thought it was your butt because it wouldn't fit on the camera.
Hey, I like that, I like that.
Um, right, I'm gonna take a very quick pause champ.
I'm gonna get some food. I'm gonna make a cup of tea.
I'm gonna go my little empty teacup here.
Oh.
But again, it'll be the same setup.
There'll be a timestamp for anyone that comes in.
I do apologise to any refunds that may have joined at any point and said hi,
and I was too busy crying.
I was too busy crying to be like, oh, I'm so glad you joined us.
As for who's streaming today, I don't have a singular clue.
I'm too busy, absolutely devastated over that movie.
VEGO is cooler than a mafia boss.
Literally, I'm about to commission my cat in a suit for the heck of it.
But yes, I'm gonna get a snack, I'm gonna heat up some leftovers.
I got a kebab, but I have some pasta left over.
I got a chicken kebab and it has, like, lettuce and onion in it
and a low lettuce and onion.
Red onion.
Hey, mome, can you mute RuneScape music?
Oh shit, sorry.
I actually left that in so it wasn't just, like, singular me talking.
Okay.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Everything's muted and I've muted in-game audio capture,
so it's literally just my voice.
That's all you're getting in the stream.
Oh, that's weird.
I mean, that's what an ASMR stream is, really.
Just give it a few more steps.
Sorry, I didn't think to do that.
Don't forget to blow your nose.
No, I'm gonna suck up all the snot to keep the nutrients inside my body.
I need every bit of hydration I've got
because I have no idea what I'm up against with these next movies.
And I swear to God, if that fucker that the Weeper Popper perishes,
I'm gonna be, I'm not even gonna be able to eat for the rest of the day
out of distress of this movie.
I swear.
Right.
Astroni can get 92 today.
She'll be halfway there.
Wow, please don't say that thing out loud.
I thought this was so much faster.
I'm ready to swap to Fletchen.
We could literally do Fletchen in four hours.
These, these wines are taking their sweet time.
Honestly.
Astroni, I thought the point of movie streams was to save your voice.
No, you need to narrate through them.
No, I'm not gonna be dead silent watching it.
Like, I'm gonna be like,
Why are this is cool?
Um, type thing.
I don't know if it was like a movie watch along
and you don't say nothing.
I feel like that's like taking the,
Yes.
Um, clutch out cooking.
You already came this far.
I asked Gimli and Vigo to help you,
but I think you need some head pads, honestly.
I wonder if Gimli's being me.
I don't at all.
I have no idea.
I like messed up my fingers so badly.
Uh, recording my Patreon audio.
I don't know if any of you are on my Patreon,
but I use my finger to do it
and I've messed up so badly.
I've got a big nasty scab on it right now
because I, I use my teeth.
I use my teeth so, my wee fingies for.
Um, the audio was good.
Like, thank you.
I was, I was jamming that thing down,
but to be honest with you.
But the problem is I have very sharp teeth.
Like, unironically,
sharp teeth.
Oh, sorry.
I need to vent your orgasm.
I forgot my microphone isn't synced for some reason,
so I'm doing vent your orgasm right now.
How are you able to hurt yourself so much?
Is that a kind of challenge?
It just, it just happens.
Literally, kind of,
Shawnee's a biter.
You want to find out?
Sharp teeth, Shawnee, honestly.
I'm a wee cuttlefish.
If you've ever seen a cuttlefish's mouth before,
or like a cephalopod's mouth,
my teeth make sense.
I, I just, I'd say finger me,
but I don't need that scab there.
Honestly, you'd probably take the scab off
from how hard you're puckering.
I'm willing to lose the tentacle.
I mean, you need sharp teeth to dig your fangs into humans
while we're in the water.
The cuttlefish attack?
I don't think cuttlefish attack, really.
I think, I think cause they're so deep seed,
it's really hard to even come across one naturally.
Remember that time that video went viral?
Cause someone who was visiting Australia
found a blue-ringed octopus
and was like touching it and playing with it.
Cause they were like,
oh, what a bright and colorful octopus.
Not knowing it's like literally 100% kill rate
if it wants to end you.
I remember that going viral
and everyone was mortified.
Just as a rule with human,
with human, with nature,
the brighter the more of a warning it is
to leave me alone.
You ever wondered why chickens are so bland in color?
Because they can hardly do a thing to you.
You want to know why tiger stripes
are such a warning sign?
Jesus.
How cute parishes did he live?
I can't remember if it was a chick
and it was a tourist
and she recorded a video of her playing with it
in the water
and it was straight up a blue-ringed octopus
and it never hurt her or anything
but if it wanted to,
so I'm going to throw up from crying so much.
I've not even had any liquid
so that burp doesn't, that burp's literally
just straight up I'm going to throw up
so upset watching John Wick.
With nature, if you don't know what it is
leave it alone, pretty much.
A ten out of ten?
I didn't even eat or anything for that.
Right, I'm going to go get some food
before we go again.
I'm going to get a cup of tea so I'll be four minutes.
I think, I don't really need to think
because I completely forgot to hydrate
and I'm dehydrating via my eyeballs right now.
I'm so...
I will hydrate when we get back.
Please, I'm going to say the S-word.
No you're not.
You want to know why cairns die their hair pink?
It's a warning so stop!
You can't say that stuff out loud
but why is it so true though?
Wait, hold on a minute.
Are you allowed to say it out loud
if it's the truth?
Hmm?
Now I don't mean to be a weirdo
but I'm allowed to say it out loud
if it's the truth question mark.
Yes? No?
I've got yes and a no.
Hmm.
Sus, sus, I don't know.
No, there's some truths that you can't speak.
Okay.
Then we will do the...
we will practice the non-speaking.
How about that?
Always speak your truth even if the world ain't right.
And they hated Strone, for she spoke the truth.
I did that meme real quick.
Honestly.
I don't know if I should say it
but we're already here.
I remember watching the YouTube channel
a couple of years back
and it was like freak out videos
of people with multi-coloured hair.
And the channel got taken down for hate
but it was just compilations
of what people had produced.
And someone was like in an atrium
swinging their arms back and forth
and it looks like they were about to fly away
but she was like screaming back and forth
with her arms. I just remember that.
Don't censor yourself, my little seaweed assassin!
Oh my god!
Assassin!
That would be my name if I was a wee assassin.
I'd be no... call me C.
Seaweed.
Why do they call you Seaweed? Oh, weed
because I'm a bit shite, to be honest.
I'm not the best. And then C because
well, the enemy kind of sees me
because I'm not very good at stealth as well.
Yeah, call me Seaweed, the assassin.
The truth is
Black Rock can't stop us now.
No, we're learning.
We're getting the information.
A danger to us even.
I was snotting the back of my nose.
You want to hear it?
Ew.
Open your mouth. That's disgusting.
I'm sorry. I just filtered one person
by doing that. I know that for a fact.
Okay.
I'm going to go make a cup of tea
and get some food. I highly
give it the hot toe.
Oh my god!
Sick GF
gives you a...
Instead of doing like her spit, she goes
like that
and then
and it's all snot.
That's disgusting. See, this is why
you can't let me come up with the ideas
and execute them because I end up
being such disgusting things.
Literally, I come out with stuff that no one
would ever think.
I legit gagged. I'm so sorry.
Disgustingly hot.
I'm so sorry. This is why you can't let
me like execute things I want
to do.
Try not to be disgusting challenge coming
up with my... No!
Try and come up with one normal ASMR idea
challenge. Literally, my first opening
line on my most recent ASMR was
the STD clinics down there.
Right, okay.
Be normal for five seconds challenge,
Ronnie. Let's go.
Right, I will be a moment.
I'll just give me a second to tingle.
I highly recommend everyone, please get
up, please get a drink, please tingle
or tingle, tingle
or please
at least stretch your legs so
you don't become absolutely clogged
like me. I think I'm already baking
a two day loaf of bread at the moment
and it's not looking good.
I'm going to have to start
sending
reeflings up there because something's not going
on. Where's Kaka and on when you need
him? He's gone far
toilet bowl and on is gone
when you needed him most.
Yeah, that first line maybe tickle.
Is this the movie marathon stream?
Yes, so we're about to do
chapter two.
We're going to start it after I go get a wee break
by a break.
I mean literally just get food to nourish
my body because I didn't eat
before stream because I don't eat before
stream because I wake up and then I stream
and then I eat.
So I'll be literally a minute
and by a minute I mean four minutes
because the kettle takes four minutes to fricking boil. I don't know why it takes so long.
I feel like my British kettle was way better
but my Aussie kettle
hooked to it.
Thanks for watching.
You
you
Are you squidding me right now?
Donating just to hear her voice again
underscore cry.
Are you squidding me right now?
you
okay now that's all out of my head I know I've muted the game sound for you
guys that's so loud in my head it's a it's like oh my goodness they done I
poor nebulosity check chair not chair chair a boy donating donating just to
hear her voice again that's Brian's voice that would play not mine
right where were we right we're gonna do part two I don't know if I should eat
first before we click play because I swear God right we're just going for it
as everyone ready for part two get your clicker clickers ready and we'll say on
go it's like three two one go okay right ready three two one go let's just
check it worked are you ready though yeah I've got leftover pasta and I put
some cheese on it it's that intro that looks like it was made in the 1990s by
Thunder root okay let me turn up the volume
is we going for a joyride are we going for a recap no hey it's Laurel and hardy
huh
are we getting into it we only just got here
is that a 1968 chavilo caviar I've got a call up I can't stand it I never wait
is a sabotage no it's not I thought it was sabotage I can't sound like it a joy
ride just how you know I got a kebab but I have leftover pasta and you finish so
I'm gonna finish up I've got kebab for leader let me just check everything's
yeah my rear view mirror that's not really my cyber oh are we getting into
it right hydration check if anyone cried alongside me by the way a couple
Bruce what do you have on your oh an insignia who do you work for who do you
work for hmm
who does number two work for oh okay not put a mother a me I use me use
again the Russians are the bad guys can the Russians be the good guys for once
how about that you'll make a crown a ground break oh new enemy introduced I
have to be that's the way I'd be sucking on our refluence tentacle that's all I'm
saying come here you know oh I ordered the pregnancy artwork I'm officially
pregnant with you right now it's gonna be here in two weeks roughly and so we're
gonna make we're gonna make the script together
okay
oh
nephew oh
okay wait we're still getting the car back
oh he already well he already showed up
oh no oh ouch ouch stunt stunt stunt doubles are crazy the scenes they do
I mean you could ask nicely honestly
you're funny
well I like the ashes had it
I
Don't fucking pencil I'm fucking do this
You
So fucking hand the car over and get back to russka to brahlusky
He's here
Previous
I
Be advocate, I'm sorry. I'd have an explosive diarrhea right there
Machine ma in your tibia machine. Yeah, I see having a stroke listening to me right now
We're on the second movie. Yes, we finished the first one. I cried my absolutely heart and soul out
I'm gonna pray
That this movie has absolutely
Nothing like the tone that was set in one
So you're saying you need to be scared in order to pass a loaf of bread
I
Speaking of a loaf of bread, I need to
Hey, I for it
And boo
Sorry, it's such a badass scene and I'm like, excuse me. Well, I pass gas
Yeah, oh
My god, wait
It's literally GT for Nico cousin want to go bowling we own a taxi rank
Get away
Be like Emmy one day maybe I
Do have a part of a donut on reward. I so bizarre honestly if you think about it
I'm gonna make a really funny short about it. Oh, he mad you just busted up my car
How much of a freaking hammer and can this car take?
They
You
They don't bell card like they used to know other things taking an absolute thrashing
Wow
Oh
Here isn't still going it should be smoking
This is not possible
Privet
No way it goes again stop
Come on, oh my god, I
Feel like we're at the end of the movie, but we've only just got started like it
I should deal you here
I
If he's still using his wee legs after getting ran over by a car
That's a heavy tank if I've ever seen one
Oh
No, I'd be gone
I
Did everyone like alcohol so much oh
None the pain sorry I forgot none the pain. Oh
Wait, he's he's offering him one last glass before well before the long
The long sleep wink wink
I
Deal you
Is he actually offering peaks I'm not going crazy
You
That this is car
This way you wanted so badly
No, not the engines flaring about
No, just need to just need to buff it out it'll buff out don't worry
I
What on earth was that intro right so the nephew isn't a problem at all then
And that's actually not our aim eat neat enemy
neat
So who's our enemy we need we need an enemy got a lot of enemies in my animal give them an enemy
I'm sorry my head to hit my
Me after my twelfth endurance stream of the month
I'm still going I'm still going you can't stop me
I
Like
Louise sound of like a car coming to a halt
I serve this is about to show me something that's gonna make me cry I swear
To God if I'm gonna choke on my past because my throat closes up from crying
It's got daisies on it which is why the dog was called
She was
No, it's fine. It's fine hold it together hold
Happy memories. It's good to have happy memories
You're allowed to have happy memories. No, don't cry. I
Am strong woman
This is fine we can do this
No, they're beautiful popper because we can love again. Oh fuck
Are you eating you
It's fine, it's fine. I'm not crying you're crying
Oh
It's fine. I'm not crying
I'm just doing my wines and Edgeville. It's fine. Everything's fine
We popper oh look I'm hit as we mark his little lie down mark. You're so smart we popper
Okay lives in a mansion and a half
Good morning. Oh, it's the fixer upper of the car depot
John makes shoes built strong issues tears. Why do you think I like binding a vising so much, huh?
Okay, I'm a photographer
Oh
Thank you
You tease and you tease and those you naughty naughty
I
Just the retirement it is
Wait he wears one particular suit oh my god, it's all smart. Yeah, it's literally straight after continuation. It's all smashed up
Wow
Just used a few pennies here and there
You're gonna have to get that cement wait first before that okay, I
Was joking but he actually is I was gonna say I was like you need to get that shit wet or you know
I'm putting rocks on top isn't really gonna hide it
Okay, so we're going back into retirement
Life's good. We've got our car. We've got our popper
You know our wife is in a place where she can't get hurt
The big sleep
Monka is
Please don't answer it
Who is it who is it who is it who's there?
Who are you oh the Italians
Fucking Chao Bella, what do you want?
I
Look at those man's
Tri-lingual oh
Cookin let's go
You're Italian you'd like a wee cafe wouldn't you you eat twat bag? Hi
You can get more stereotypical could you John your ignorance is showing
You're telling you knew you must want an espresso
Not until after 6 p.m. You can't have an espresso in the morning
Against the rule oh next you're gonna ask him to fucking harvest the tomatoes in the back garden and shove them in jars next
John your ignorance is showing me
I just start doing the hands
To my popper uh not yet. What do we name them?
I'm not sure what to name the popper Daisy so come Duke
Daisy Duke Spooky
No, what the fuck is that?
It's a summon a sigil
Lore
Lore and Italian is impossible task with us
I
Know
Ask him a sort of blood contract no
Are you fucking Italian she'll do Italian
Your fingerprint in blood. Oh
I'm not that guy pal. I'm not that guy
I don't see saying that to him brother back off him
I
Did we just make enemies by rejecting
Did we just make enemies with the whole of Italy is
The Vatican mad at us
I
Ehh?
Oh there's an enemy lady, did you catch that?
Looks like an enemy lady back there.
Normally they shy away from showing any violence against ladies in movies.
But that looked like a lady enemy in the back.
Ehh?
No, are you joking?
A fucking grenade launcher?
You have to be kidding me.
Oh my god, please tell me the dog lives.
Are you serious?
Please tell me the dog's just chilling in the kennel in the back garden.
Oh thanks.
Oh thank god!
Didn't he do that to me again?
John Wick development team and writers and all that.
The thing just chilling- oh no!
The necklace and everything is gone!
This man can't have shit!
Oh my god, at least he's got his pupper!
Holy fuck, he's becoming a monk!
He's letting go of everything he loves, fuck.
I'm trying to give it a positive twist so I don't cry.
He just wants to practice being a monk, okay?
And he's getting rid of everything he loves,
because that's the monk way or something like that, I can't remember.
Tell me?
I can't answer him.
Oh my god!
He knows he's working.
Oh look at the dog!
Okay, I finished my thingy.
Jimmy's a goat, literally.
Jimmy's like, alright, alright, alright.
Oh we went to the continent, oh!
Oh my god, that dog is constantly looking for his cue.
He's so cute!
Look at it looking at his hand for a treaty when he does the right cue.
Don't say no pets, I'll cry.
Don't say no pets, I'll actually greet.
Now the dog can come into the conversation.
It needs to know too why it's who's just got blown to smithereens legs.
Okay, what's this?
The cement didn't even have time to dry before people started picking fight skin, literally!
Okay, what's going on here?
Good afternoon, hotel owner, Mr. Winston.
Big Winnie-Billy.
Winston!
I'm having my tea, please remember to hydrate, Riflin.
If you cried like me as well during the scene a little.
I didn't cry, I may have cried a little.
But I didn't cry though, because I'm a big girl.
Dad's giving us some smack talk.
Sorry dad, we messed up.
But he was a different person back then, he's not the same big Johnny boy, he's different.
I'm a big girl, you said later me or Asa.
Okay, daddy's telling us what's up.
Okay, our options have been laid out before us.
What a smart pupper, honestly.
Can you make an exception?
Thank you! Yes, yes, yes, please!
I trust him in your hands wholeheartedly.
Aw, I trust him with the wee pupper.
I'll be back soon, don't worry.
I need to go on a badass mission against the Italians.
That's right, I'm just going to say random Italian phrases I picked up from Assassin's Creed.
What are you going to do about it?
Oh, it's the enemy lady.
Don't think, oh my god, yeah, yeah, you're feeling those pecs.
That's right, you like my pecs, don't you? Yes.
Actually, your hair's short, this might indicate a different kind of interest.
Hey, what team do you bat for? What's going on here?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, a little sheebie move right there, what the heck?
That was my back door. Back off! Back off!
You foul beast.
I have a wife, you know.
She's in either, but I'm going to her very soon.
Fucking miscoosie, that was my arsehole chick.
Accidental prostate exam whilst you're getting patted down for guns, like, or eight of them.
And yet you did.
Yeah, probably.
With a fucking pencil.
Ooh.
I should dance, huh?
Who is it?
He wants in.
Never for the Italian.
Oh, well, I mean, isn't there a reason that the father thought?
Oh, she in Roma? I'm getting flashbacks to Assassin's Creed.
To say ghost in French, you say Lufantum, repeat.
I'll correct, say a Borgia, a big chisory Borgia going on here.
Oh, she's in Rome. I love my sister, but I can't kill her.
Everyone's in their own world.
Everyone's doing their own thing, got their own problems, that was a good shot.
I like that train shot, or subway cart shot.
Mm-hmm.
Man, he really likes his Balenciaga, like, he's like, no, so I can't be the boogeyman if I've no got my nice and tidy wee shirt and shoes on.
He's got, look, he's got a method, all I'm saying, he's got a method and it works.
Oh, okay, I take it back. I apologize. That was kind of really obvious, it wasn't just clothes, I'm sorry, I'm dumb.
He doesn't want to do it, he's angry. I got scared there.
It's because he's angry, he doesn't want to do it.
That actually don't scare me, I'm gonna lie like this.
Rome, it was not built in a day.
Alright, what's the first bank we blow up?
The people cannot owe debts if there's no one to owe the debts to.
And remember, the banks are just entities at the end of the day, they are concepts.
Is that her?
I'm sorry, I shouldn't have said that out loud, I'm getting a bit too carried away.
I'm sorry, John Wick's going through me, I shouldn't have said that.
So is this...
Of course it seems Julius, they didn't even try.
The YouTube transcript's probably going wild, true.
This stream is going to be a limited ads, I just know it.
No. No. No.
No, no, we're not here for the Pope.
Why would there be a head on the Pope?
Thank you.
I wonder what's inside the room.
Is there gonna be pew-pews?
God, everyone freaking knows us, we're so popular, Reflins.
How are you so popular?
You miss the word why? I mean, the Pope should be on the...
I mean, if there's religious tax exemptions, why don't the people get it?
Curious.
Do we not believe in ourselves?
Do we not have hope in ourselves? Do we not have souls?
You.
Thank you very much, Lady, for leading us to the...
How does he speak so many lingos?
Curious.
I need to do a suit measuring ASMR for you guys.
When I get down to the area, you already know I'm going to be hovering.
Oh, inseam, that's what it's called, inseam on the suit.
I need to wear wear.
All the economy and monetary traffic behind that in Italy is another way to talk about the mafia.
11.5 inches, how's anyone supposed to fit that?
Teasing.
A badass sweatshop lady, hello?
She's a trained assassin?
Yeah.
Manila and foils.
Oh, I've not seen that.
Am I?
My hands get wet at the end of an evening too.
It's just too easy, I'm sorry.
Oh my god, it's Mercy Modest!
I hate myself, I hate myself, why did I come up with that?
Next, so we fondle abysm.
Late epic joke.
Oh, sorry, my wee chair clip just came off.
Anyone else? Happy hunting.
He has a bit more tact with it.
I might need to burp a little.
Fortune's Fortuna means good luck or something.
Fortuna, bonafortuna is good luck.
What does this back tattoo say?
Someone googled it for me right now.
What does John Wicks tattoo say?
Type that in right now, go.
Something fortune, fortune favors the bold.
I knew it was fortune.
I knew it, I knew it.
Fortuna, Fortuna means fortune.
Oh, it's Latin?
Oops.
I remember my mum said she took Latin in school and I was like, ain't that lingo dead?
And I was like, well, dead spoken but or something, I don't know.
Oh look, he's gone up the cobblestones where the horsies used to clop-a-dee-clop up.
Oh, did you hear they found a new room in Pompey with blue wallpaper paint?
Like blue paint on the walls.
I'm so sorry if that's really boring.
But Pompey is the, I don't know, Ashen site of the volcanic in Italy
and they discovered a new room that used blue wall paint
and there's something about the paint that's really specific
because it got phased out in culture or something
and they don't know what the connection is with Italy having access to this blue paint.
Whoa, AC again!
Come on, AC, have you got the blue going for her?
Oh, come on, AC, take it away.
You look nothing like AC but it's close enough, close enough.
Okay, maybe AC is on the DJ stand and not the singer.
Because...
Il Colosseum.
Oh?
Target acquired.
And the wise words of...
Look how low the bass player's, the guitar guy's legs were.
He was like squatting playing the guitar there.
I'm so sorry.
Italy taking a little, little ducky.
That's a man, so that ain't AC on it.
Look how low his wee legs are getting, sorry.
It looks very strange.
I think maybe because he's wearing skinny jeans, he looks like a little stick.
He looks like a praying mantis playing the guitar.
Where's wee legs going then?
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I think I'm delirious from all the crying earlier.
He's literally going to end up then just playing the guitar.
I'm so sorry.
Honestly.
I need a fur.
I almost popped a blood vessel.
Try and get that one out.
The praying mantis confirmed absolutely not.
Oh, cutthroat business women.
Maven Black Briar, clearly.
That's a Skyrim reference for you, if you want.
Oh, I'll refresh in your makeup all right.
Glup, glup, glup.
Oh, wait.
What is this little paper?
Are we in here with her?
No.
That was so cool.
I have a lot of friends.
Oh, no.
I like the way they've done subtitles.
Your brother.
You have to tell her who.
She knows, she knows, she knows, she knows.
Now for a seat at this table.
My way.
Yes.
She understands, no.
She's not even mad, like she understands.
We can't win.
She understands, she's not going to fight or anything.
She accepts it with grace.
Oh, my lady.
My lady.
My lady, I didn't even see that.
Wait, I don't understand.
Is she like poison up her butt or something?
Is she just, I think she's accepting it.
Well, considering he's maintaining eye contact,
I only look at my wife.
Oh, her hair clip was a weapon.
But she chose not to.
Oh, my God, she's actually accepting it.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Out on her own terms.
Oh, please.
It doesn't have to be this way.
She doesn't want exploded.
Oh, my God, that visual is so cool.
No, darling.
Oh, no.
Oh, that symbolism, though.
Look at the way her feet crossed over.
Please don't think I didn't catch that symbolism in her pose.
No.
Oh, that feels so terrible.
It was your brother.
Oh.
We're here for you.
Oh, I feel so sad for her.
No.
Oh.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait.
Oh, she asked to go pretty.
John, she asked to go pretty.
That's why she did that.
She didn't want a big blast on her freaking cranium.
For fuck's sake, men don't understand.
She wanted to be a pretty corpse on her own terms for fuck's sake, John.
AC, you better turn them tunes down, I'm region.
John, you dance.
Oh, no.
We got clocked.
Ah.
Oh, she didn't know.
Good night.
Oh.
She did get to go out on her own way.
I know John has to confirm the job, but...
Oh, I guess team is of the essence.
You can't be messing around.
Fucking AC, get it.
On stage?
Wait, they think it's a plot?
Like a...
Okay, okay.
Uh, high civilian casually, right?
What?
A good blood detail on the kills.
Yeah.
Oh, she's gone.
Damn, they must have had to edit the Krammer crew out of that mirror shot.
I just...
Oh, it hurts.
A bullet just dropped off of him, that's actually such a good detail.
I wouldn't even consider that, but yeah, if a bullet gets stopped,
it could just be attached to the core of him.
I think we just got the patchy.
I'll actually just pop him off like a bit ASMR,
but like bullets like popping off of a bullet thing.
Well, I can't even see shit, I don't even know about you, lads, but...
Fuck it, I'll need my glicks on for this scene.
It's a bit cloudy.
It's the lady.
He double-crossed us?
We were double-crossed?
Well, now we can't let him take the throne at all.
He is not getting a seat at the high table.
If anything, I'll take over for the Italians myself.
Uh, first business, um...
First business, um...
I don't know, I don't know what business.
More Italian vichaburus, yay!
First business.
We bring anime to Italy.
All I'm saying is, hear me out, lollipop, pope.
Make it a meatball.
A lollipop, honestly.
That's actually really good, I wish I could do that.
Mmm, that's not crillage.
Well, look at the way that mag went flying.
U stationed, south-east.
Well, we're taking a hammer-in.
U don't know what to do.
Well, we'll see you there later.
come on reflins come on reflins you can do it
yeah I'm gonna have to admit fidgety ammo reload not a fan
too precise with the amount of adrenaline that would go through you too
precise for a reload although John Wick's probably used it now
brutal a brutal
you are not winning against a showy
the spread on the pellets can be just so just too much John probably forgets how
to reload when he doesn't have adrenaline literally start missing in
stuff he's like hey where's that where's the shaky hands he's already used to the
shake
I'm off to do a tourist attraction where will we go first
whoa how about we help the Sistine Chapel let's go let's go the Sistine
Chapel moment
that's too fast
oh
oh I hate having to perish people that we already know
just let us walk away that's all you had to do but no no so is but if I'm
just like a regular mercenary and Baba Yaga is my target I'm like saws me I
didn't see anything so I was I was tying my shoelaces so I was I was looking on
the floor oh that scene would hurt so much my back hurts just thinking of
that oh my back my spine oh please hold on pause my back I don't have any fat on
the spine please mercy mercy no more oh my gosh
oh I'm no laughing anymore I like that little I'm stop missing
come on oh get off your bum come on get on get on no no no no no come on John
oh come on John give it to the egg oh come on come on come on oh stop missing
come on oh my god you're wait wait they can't they can't fate they're inside they
can't fight who's gonna fix that windy no no you don't need to remind me I'm
sorry sir yes sir thank you sir
okay yes yes okay maybe we don't want to kill the egghead I'm not sure I'm a
cracker you gonna thank you thank you very much
you want to talk about it buddy no
family again family business family business yeah it wasn't for fun buddy
he's retired well what well really did we forget the double-cross loose end
oh there you go Jen is just dry vodka ward I've never heard Ward used like that
Ward means a spell on the floor my ward so rifling is my ward I'm sorry bro but
you ain't winning this one
Ward Ward means someone who is under your protection hmm I guess a ward spell
makes
Ward is someone you have to protect so I protect you and you protect me so we're
both wards for one another okay I'm learning new words and it's all thanks to
John Wick to the hit movie series did you know John Wick 5 is in production yeah
no grats you me or death
jw forget try lingual this man's hand lingual as well next you're gonna tell
me he's cunning lingual okay sorry I was so close that is a good joke I just
executed terribly I tried I tried hmm probably just me yeah I was gonna see
cuz if you're deaf and in mercenary work you kind of need to be able to hear
where the bullets are coming well actually if your ears are oh no is that
the only thing that had the video on it
a
chop in the big of youth
Oh
oh
Oh, spaghetti, oh, oh, you've done it now mate, you've done it now.
A man of so little words, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh that high chair isn't guaranteed bro.
You may think that upgrade is yours and no, no, no, no, no, no.
Fortune favour the soap holes.
I like how the music..
I
Bounty to who?
Oh
Are we getting a 7 million bounty put on our head for like everyone not just one party
No
Everyone is our enemy
No like this
Oh
No, no, no, we can't show her face
No
I'm so stressed right now. I'm so stressed on behalf of you refling you have a 7 million bounty on your head
You didn't tell me about
There's
Oh
When he's not pleased and beg when he's no pleased
I'd betray every flim for seven you know
That he just left
I
Could you mods get that man when he knows it's a say open nuts brand has been made to the fall guy
You mean the hit jellybean game fall guy, sorry
He's coming again for you first assassin
Oh
No everyone
Wait isn't he a famous sumo wrestler in Japan unironically
I mean if I was a tank build I'd do the same, but
Al my fucking's kidney
Oh my god, no, I'm bleeding out. No, no, no, no
Oh, that's your DNA bro, you want to keep that
Uh
Remember keep your DNA to yourself unless asked otherwise
What
No, yeah, come on just leave us alone
Now the fucking South Koreans are getting in on this come on come on give us a second to breathe
Oh
Can't look I can't look I can't look I'm not
Right, I can't I can't handle that. I don't know why I can't handle that. Okay. Okay. It's fine. It's gone. It's fine. Oh
Goodness gravy
He did it. Oh
Oh, no, no, no the scene came back
Oh
That guy's HP bar was like legit. Oh
My god, he has to scan everyone. No, please
I
Here's to go to the Continental
That's the all
Come is that green screen green screen
Well, I mean
Oh
Come on we need to get to the Continental like now so we can catch a breather and heal up
Excuse me, pardon me coming through sorry, I've got business really important business meeting to attend. Sorry. I can't he miss it
I truly can't he miss my important business meeting truly
Business business business yep CEO papers and stuff like that business business business
Oh
Stop
Stop this nonsense with your suppressors
Stop. Oh, that's getting a bit silly Billy if I've ever seen that silly Billy
That's silly Billy behavior. You stop that whoever wrote that scene you do we silly Billy aren't you?
That was silly. I like
I
Nail he just a motor down. I'm give him a little 360 twirl
Oh my god, he's got a gun we don't question mark we're out of ammo
Uh, can we jump on that train?
No
Not in public they're civilians
Are we even heading to the Continental do we even know what direction we're going in is it easy to navigate New York?
I don't think so
I
Everyone's giving John looks because he's covered in blood
There's too many people around don't do it
Real one well
Unwritten rule one no civilians because rule one was no business in the Continental
Oh, come on. Are you telling me this train is gonna perfectly empty? Oh
Come on
This is bigger that's cheating
It has to be the same you call that a north this is a north
Nervous oh
Oh
Oh, we're just two people catching up on the train, please. That is we're just having a wee fight. It's okay
Don't be scared. We mean no harm. We're just having a wee bicker. We had a business deal go sour
That's why I'm in a suit. I'm just a businessman
La da da da
No, we're both just British. Okay. Don't worry. We're from London. It's perfectly normal
Don't please don't be scared. Please don't report us
We're just practicing our WWE debut, okay, if it looks legit, you know, we've made it
Come no
Oh
Okay
Honestly, I'd be clearing off that train too that that WWE fate ended a pretty look really too realistic for me if I'm being honest
I think we've still not made it to the continent. Oh
Come on or my Kamara the car will do as well. Oh god. It's so
Oh, please a
Single moment to heal is all I ask
Hi
Help me a buddy
Oh
With friends like these with friends like these oh my god, I would absolutely love to develop a
With friends like these oh my god, I would love to develop a game where you make friends with a homeless, sorry and
Like you help them out and then they help you out and then you end up running like this massive underground like naughty naughty thing
I feel like that'd be so cool
Cuz I'm sure there was a movie that was like who's the most unignored like ignored person in society that you'd never expect
and it's like the homeless because like
some
Nations think homelessness is like a choice and some people like maybe don't realize like how strong addiction is
Still person there, you know
There's still a lot of things going on. Okay, he's healing up. We're healing up
We've got an IV to hydrate. That's what I need to get my loaf of bread out
I'll let you key IV here in there. So I'll just order a weekly IV
Bum simulator no, but we end up running like a massive like money mill and then we blow up the banks
Oh, I'm gonna develop that game. I don't care. Sorry
I'm gonna work hard right first get the girls a
Stable content creators unhappy next retire my dad third
Homeless Empire where we we don't have debt anymore. Oh
Come on my dad come on. You have to let me do it. You have to let me do it
I don't care what how we're gonna do it
I am contacting the ballot roll guy as we speak cuz
He's gonna absolutely dominate in a game simulator thing like that
Hi pretty birdie. Oh, that's nice
Wait, oh my god, it's the main way they come together. They're matrixes. They're both make tricks. I players
Good afternoon
I'm not much, okay
There's news Morpheus
She really late fake love. I can't wait to watch it again with you
I
Because now you guys
Understand see before I couldn't really let on I couldn't really see
But now I can see why I absolutely adored that movie
Let it all
Oh, is that us are you sure you're not mistaken us for someone else
Okay, I'm sorry, I didn't mean it was a mistake, okay. Yeah, yeah
No, please don't hurt the bird
No, you love the bird, you're not gonna hurt it
Yeah
His name was Robert Paulson, my name was fun to lapism. There's a game called fan. Hey and to go prophecy
Oh, I might play that then
Applebee's apparently Applebee's is like witherspoons where you can get drunk, but there's like lunch and stuff there
With friends like these
Come on, come on, you know, we'll do a favor
No, oh
What problem
Oh, no, he's still laughing taking a seat
Shout out to the sound engineer that mashed those laughs together
Oh
Wow, those are RPGs
They track it oh, there's me look it's you every flinger on the wall, sorry
I keep saying it's me and you both of us are John Wick
It's fancy dinner, but I'm a cheapskate Applebee's
Of course, I'm John Wick. He's literally
You
But if John does it
Oh
89 89
Sorry the movie's that serious part but level 89
Almost halfway there
Somebody please
Get this refunds ink
Are you trolling are we being trolled
We're being trolled right seven sip bell
I
You know
No, that's what
The ball is that are you a joke?
For seven bullets, I owe you none
Actually, yeah, the last guy that would me a auto him well, he's gonna perish so
Oh my god, that's me on the violin for real
Did you guys get to do any musical instruments at your school? I did swimming
I was on the I was on the athletics team like a little narrate. I never did any music stuff
I did swimming in athletics because I was a fast runner
And then I became slow when I hit puberty because my hips came and then my hips fucked me up
I
Float and a guitar hot cross buns
That's that you guys have to send me an audio of you playing hot cross buns if you've got room right, sorry poor
Sorry, I'm getting distracted piano
Dilly-dilly sort of swimming my favorite musical instrument. No, I meant in place of any music
I did athletics and stuff
I did the high jump and I did swimming and I did running and I did hurdles
I was in the flight a little beam
And I play basketball sometimes but it's winter so I can't play basketball right now
Hydration check I'm gonna get some water and we're gonna see if we can drop a dookie
Oh
Enemy spotted
Oh, let's just give them a nice easy shot line up why not
Hydration hydration
Winter it's almost July
Give it take his gun take his gun take his gun gun take it take it it's got like six in the chamber
Four five
Reload reload reload
Oh
Was someone please think of his Spain
He says a secret melee I
Must take a while to scavenge for more ammo honestly
That's a serious museum
Wait, what was that in the background that looked like a
Did anyone see that red artwork it looked like a figurine
I
Well, it's gone. No, but
Huh
I'm a tool ah peel V you enter Vietnamese nail salon
Oh
Nope, I'm a dumb sorry
And John Mike villains be like surely if we say more guys he'll perish
I
I'm terrible for appreciating art unless it's like the old drawn stuff like at the Vatican in that
Is it sent and you know that I can appreciate
Modern art I'm absolutely rubbish with I'm like mmm. Yes, okay. I probably could have done that in sunny Vegas
Oh
And you double crossed me
This is your penance not mine or no the bad ladies back
Oh testament eye for an eye
It's already bad bro, so you need to pay
That must be terrifying walking into if you're like a later group
Well, there's your answer
I
Excuse me
Oh you can he be saying that stuff to me
Give me that gun it's got 30 per round
No, you're wasting my ammo don't be selfish give me the gun
Okay, yeah, that's fine throw it. It's fine. It's fine
Okay
Modern art is another way of monderland it launder money
Okay, first rule when we take over Italy is
You're not allowed to pay over a certain amount for artwork and it should be historical smile
You
Ain't laundering nothing
This is exactly why I'm not getting any see in any political thing because they would probably eliminate me they'd be like
Oh all the slander campaigns off
They'd be like yeah, she made Emmy. This is why she can't be
Oh
Don I need to
Squeeze them
Oh
Ah
Holy crap the
You know shout out to the CGI team that had to literally edit out the cameras and every single scene that you're seeing right now
You ain't gonna see her
He knows he's not gonna see her he knows
Shh
Ah
Get that away from me you fevel winch
The only one that penetrates me is my wife
Yeah, oh
Oh
I'm sorry, I had to be this way
Um
I'm sorry, I had to be this way holy crap
Are you gonna finish her off be oh shit, it's over it's over look at the breathing
It's over
Oh
Oh, he's in the continental sugar you seek refuge
Bonvieto
Big Winnie are you gonna ask big Winnie for a favor you were warned
You were warned
Oh
Winston pop in that fat shlong on the table
He really said I own the company and it's not indebted to the banks
Be seeing you a reviewer, sorry, I read a dirtie big man
Hi
No, mr. Wick
Wait rule one hello, why is he got his gun out no one
No, he's not gonna be that silly put the gun away mr. Wick my motions are high
But you know the rules and constant and opal no other one other word it begins with sissy
our difference
Why is it not putting it away a
We bit of potato wiping it in the gravy of the food
Delicious
Okay
Oh
No
No, what did we just do I
I
Think you're my cat remember
What have we just done
Can we get pardoned by the high table maybe
Maybe maybe maybe oh, we don't have a home. No
Oh
It's in tears and it's wet just to add injury to insult insult injury. Oh
We don't even have a roof
Oh
My god, he's sitting in the rain
No
Is there anything the photo do we have a photo at least oh
Her necklace survived. Thank goodness. Oh
Thank goodness. What about daisies? What about daisy daisies we call her
I've done that wrong
Oh
Hey, hey
My good friend, yes
Inclined for what?
Sitting in the rain in the rain. I am the rain. Hi, Marcy
We're watching John Wick to our house got blown up when we were sitting in the rain with no roof. I
Don't know what's about to happen though
Continental as a sanctuary and he's tainted
Wait is the dogs gonna be okay though, I'm not handling it as the dogs. No fine
Can you take the dog?
No, no, no
No, my good friend
Oh my god, it's a watch along androidscape such multi-tasking. Yes
It's to try and save my voice because I talk all the way whenever I do an endurance stream
If I'd end up doing runescape tomorrow, I'm watching all your guys's stream as well
So I can catch up on streams that I want to watch from years. Oh
No, oh
No, daddy's mad. I'm sorry dad. I didn't mean it
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry
14 million international
I'm genuinely stressed
I
Know I understand I understand
I comprehend
What you mean
I
These are
Not one actual tourist was in there hold on a minute
Everyone stops in the one tourists is like what the fuck's going on here. Is this a flash mob? I
Love her mother and I love my daughter
I
Favor
Oh my god
I've got chills I'm scared refund. I'm scared of you
You're too powerful for me refund what the heck oh
No, he has to put it in
I'll give him no
No, he has to he doesn't have a choice
The oh, he's the og
He's the og he's
No, no, no
He's literally the og account number one
I wonder where he'd start to get anywhere. Oh
No
Oh
Worldwide we're oh, no
No, no, no
No
What country are we going to quick pick a country uh if it lands on heads we're going to poland if it's tails
We're gonna be a poppy farmer in pakistan fuck it
Oh my god, everyone's contracts going live
The contract's going live
It's the dog there it is
Oh
No, our buddy we have to leave him behind is he gunning for us
Come on tiddlesworth keep keep those running up
Oh my god, oh my god, what we're in so much trouble. We're in so much trouble
Oh
We're in so much trouble
Reiflin, what did you do?
You couldn't have poisoned them you had to shoot on point blank in front of all those witnesses
Maybe if it was just Winston and they could like clean up the body really quickly and be like oh, no
We don't know where you went smile. He just didn't show up for work in the morning
Oh
Oh, we had to do it we had no choice
In the dark right i'm gonna see if i can drop a big fat idol meeting wink wink um
Oh
I am so stressed watching these movies like i am genuinely so stressed in all the scenes. I'm like, oh my god. What happens?
Um
That was so good. I only cried a tiny bit in that one
Uh, so we're doing good. Okay, that's when you know i'm doing good. Right. Let's do that
Oh, it's chapter 70. Yeah, well, it's just gonna be credit
Okay, next movie, please
It's opening pause
Right. Okay. Uh, we're on john wick three
I am going to take a big fat steaming log or i'm going to attempt to if it wants to come out. It's up to it
Um, and then we will start the movie together
Yeah, sounds like a deal only cried for half an hour wall
Literally, I can't handle any sad film
So if anyone's like, oh when are you going to watch this sad film? Never
I literally can't handle it. My eyes are so puffed up right now. I'm like
I'm wishing that. Oh wait, I forgot. I'm supposed to be a ventriloquist because for some reason my microphone is out of sync for a second
So it looks really weird. Hello, and I'm starting calls. Let's go. I'm also a ventriloquist. Hey
I'm gonna be a hot second
I think I'll make another cup of tea. I don't know. I'm not decided yet. I'm gonna see if I can drop a stinking log. Okay
Okay
So know how to train your dragon. Is it sad? I've I read the first book of how to train your dragon. Is it not sad?
Okay, right
I've actually not seen how to train your dragon like after the first one
I don't know if I saw the second one, but I remember the first one because fish legs
Isn't looking how he looks in the thingy
Right. I I'm going to see if I can drop a turd. Please do stretch get some food. Blah. Blah. Blah. Blah. I'm sorry
King Kong's finger is calling
You
Are you squidding me right now
Strongly fighting the toilet demons stay strong reeflings
You
Guess who took a steaming job a strike ladies and gentlemen me
My dude it came out. I'm not constipated. Let's go. It means I can do an adjourn stream tomorrow
Yes
99 cooking here. I come you come come
A christmas miracle no animal animal animal no animal required
How was the fight I had to squeeze that bad boy out all I'm saying seven minutes it took me seven minutes to take a job
Sorry
Took my sweet time normally my bit more hydrated comes flying out at me if I have to be honest
Uh right
Right right right right wait hold on
pause
doomsday dan
sassafras boy
Strongly fighting the toilet demons stay strong. No genuinely. I was on the
And then it you know
It all went well. How do we feel about john wick so far? I am blown away by the series
I am very nervous for what's about to occur in movie number three
So very quick recap if I understand correctly
We have been excommunicadoed and now all assassins worldwide have a 14 million
us dollar
bounty
On the head of beloved john wick or it also known as refling also known as me because
I insert us into movies because I think it's fun to be like are we gonna get do it?
Come on you can do it like I like doing that. I don't know if that's just me
but yeah
This is one of the many reasons why I love you because you explain in such detail
Your horrendous fight in the why is it called a restroom if I'm fighting for my life in here?
Okay
As everyone got john
Three opened up also. Congrats. If your name's john john john johnny jonathan john
I'm scaring the absolute crap out of the one person that's called john right now
Apologies, um
Or if your name's winston, but I think you would be an og san if you're a winston because that's kind of like a later name big johnny boy
Um, I have to go to sleep now. Thank you so much for the stream
No, thank you so much for the stream because I just get to fucking goof off and edge myself and edgeville with wines
I'm sorry. I don't know why I said that part out loud
um
I'm starting to lose the filter slightly. I I think because of the emotional turmoil that was the first, um
Movie I have to admit. I did not recall any of those sad scenes
and
I only cried a little bit in the second one. So surely by the third movie. I'm not shedding any tears
Surely there shall be no tears shed. I'm a big girl. Okay
Um, I have two hours 10 minutes and 46 seconds. You can actually see it up top
It's loaded one second in how cheeky of this
No tears here. Maybe hopefully not
Um
Right, are we all ready? Do we have movie number three opened up?
Okay
Three on go on go. We say we do on go. Okay three two one go
Let us see sorry, I did that far too early all the wines
Let us see what movie number three has in store for us
Now that we have a 14 million bounty on our head. I don't even know what that would be in today's money
I feel like it would probably have inflated to like 21 million at least
Um
I have two hours and 10
Well, I I have an extra second because my dad works at microsoft there. Take that
Yeah, what's the dealio here? Oh
Whoa, we're getting straight into it lines gate does not hold back holy crap
Right, let's check it out. Let's check it out. Let's check it out. Right. We've got a mark
We remember we got a mark from winston. We got a phone a friend from winston
so
Oh, also, uh, my heart rate monitor is here
So we might be able to do
Um, what's that game called on nintendo where you run about?
Ring fit is coming up
Uh, and I also have my cables to do my 10k celebration in the bath
ASMR stream
The cables are ridiculously long like stupendously long
So i'm gonna test if my iPhone can track me in the bathroom. It's not that far away from the pc
Oh, we're getting straight into the action. Okay. Okay, we can do this
Come on popper. You're coming with me
Right contract is live excommunicado
Ring fit, yeah
No, I'm not doing ring fit in the tub. It'll be a separate stream
I'm saying I have a heart rate monitor so I can maybe I can start using it
Um, I keep forgetting to message
Uh
sing
Sing sister
Sorry, I'm getting mega distracted now. I'm like, oh
14 million bounty highest bounty there is
Oh my god
Well, we can't even go to the continental they have the rights. Wait, do they have the rights to perishers of the continental or am I being daft?
Question mark do we have refuge?
Is refuge so offered to us? I don't know. Oh, that's not even us. That's winston. Okay. It's not even us. Hold on
Oh
Oh winston said hold on a minute. Let's make it even Steven
Shit we've only got a coin left
No, no, no, no
No, no, no, no, no, no
They're not friendly either now everyone is literally our enemy
Isn't the dog getting cold? Oh wait, I was gonna say this dog has short fur
Aren't these dogs not suited for weather like that?
Winston knows how it is
A library
What does he know that we don't know a library?
I
Stuck
Oh
Yeah, we don't even have a name for him. Okay, he's gonna be safe. Don't cry. It's just a little bit sad, but it's okay
He's gonna be safe. He's safe. He's safe. That's that's fine
Now we need to make sure reefing safe
Fuck you know right what happens in the library. What's so special about a library? There must be something in it
I
Shoes clacking on the ground while everyone's trying to study and research
What's up the library
Uh
Anytime no
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you
Thank you. Thank you. Sorry. Didn't mean to rush you there with my body language. Just
Just russian for that russian book
Okay, well, I'll try it. I tried look it's tense. I'm trying to ease the tension of the the move
Hey
Oh, baby girl, she was in her book
What is this so someone else's mark
Who can we call in a favor from?
Oh
My beloved
Oh, you fill him with determination every time
Oh
Fuck you now you need to get your pituitary gland checked out bro. You're a bit lanky
That's danger, I think he's actually got a pituitary gland hopefully got dealt with
We're in a library this place is sacred for knowledge and wisdom stop it. This isn't wisdom. Oh my fucking shoulder
Fucking get oh look at where the knife landed. That's so cool
How big is this library
Oh my god, he's oh, he's like slender man. I don't like him. I'm sorry
Oh, look how long his arms are they're about the size of john winks abdomen
Oh
No, I mean
I know he's a bad day, but john you're brutal reflin
Oh my god
That was my shoulder
Man, we're gonna have to have like stakes to repair get all this iron back for hemoglobin
Do you know how much hemoglobin we lose every time we get into our fate?
And he put the book back correctly what king honestly we're brilliant mommy. Do you want to try I try
I'll let you guys uh
Wait so folk are trying to do it before they actually should
That's a lot of money
No
Mate
We did you a favor
You just don't know it we did you a favor, but you don't know it
I
No, don't take the money just let him in
No, you weren't followed
Please fix my shoulder. No wait, we don't have to kill the old man. Do we no we like the old man. He helps us
Please
Yeah
Okay, it's
Wow, I'm so stressed. I thought movies were supposed to be like a good little thing
Please tell me the old man doesn't turn on us. Please be like you old man
Oh
A minute less than a minute
Oh my god, boss man, please boss man boss man
Boss man who's gonna know close the blinds
No
He can't oh
Okay, old man doesn't want to hurt us. It's because he can't finish the job. Okay. That's good
Oh
Boss man a friend indeed. Thank you boss man for trying your best with the time that you had. Thank you
Oh dear oh dear oh dear oh dear
No, no, no
Oh
Oh boss man
The whole city's looking for your reflin
Thank you boss man. Thank you. Thank you
No, he's not whoa
No
No, no, no, come on every fell my fucking cry
Are we about to do what I think we're about to do?
No
No, he he can live he can live he's a doctor he knows
Oh
Okay, no, it's fine. He knows how to he instructed us he knows it's fine. It's fine. He'll breathe
Okay, okay, it's fine. It's fine. It's fine. He didn't have to perish. He just had to receive
unbelievable amounts of pain
like indescribable
uh
An ordeal
most PTSD inducing
experience
rewiring your brain to fear pain beyond levels unknown
That the human mind cannot comprehend but thank you doctor for having her back. We appreciate it
Oh, I feel so sorry. Hopefully he can wait. We didn't even give him some morphine tablets to put in his tum tum
I know morphine's a drip, but come on
Okay, I'm finally having my tea
Wow
Classic elbow in the glass. Yes, I love when movies do that
You
Uh a revolver too long to reload
Not that we have much of a ah they're coming
Oh my god
Oh my god, forget Mustang and Sally. This thing's ancient. We'll be cleaning the pipe out between every shot
Oh my god snub news. Oh, no, sorry idiot. Idiot is freaking detached
I was like really a snub news pistol. I mean it'll work. I'll take anything at this point
He really just
Yeah, John Wick cowboy unlocked from the south
Revolvers can't jam though reload time though
No, not yours doesn't belong to you get off it
We are destroying someone's collection right now
Ah my freaking head
Oh, hey, that was a cheap shot. I think that would just say I'm not gonna lie
I'm pretty sure you can disable a guy by punting them in the balls
Or you know just ah gun gun. Okay. Okay. Okay
We almost just got a vasectomy for free
Oh my god
Ow! Ow ow ow. Oh his lungs. Oh he-
OH! It's an-
Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. It's fine. It's fine. We're winning. We're winning
Oh my gosh
Oh he's got a hammer or not hammer what those called is an axe.
A hatchet?
A hatchet.
Oh please no more my goodness.
Oh my god that must have been a nightmare to re-shoot for cos you would have to fix
all the glass panels every time.
AHHHH!
Oh I didn't like that one!
Oh!
Right in his wee...
Right...
Fucking right down to the yoke!
Oh no no no no I'm not looking I know exactly where that scene is going sorry from the no
I know I know exactly what he just did there I know exactly what he just did there and
I didn't have to look oh my gosh I'm not looking at that oh my god is it gonna oh yes holy
oh oh oh the goods have been delivered I repeat the payloads have arrived the payload has
been delivered to safety all is good once more
oh how does his body not give up twice oh my god he's soaked to the bone as well
oh my god horse feature were confirmed for gen 2 no the odds of a horse girl and a slain
girl the exact same no eh none of the horses better get hurt in this film we'll be region
perfectly being in the way that is not how horses are in a stall that looks like they're
getting rid of well that guy's a goner John Wick vtuber when right now whoa oh my god
go nature help us nature help us wait isn't there a horse feature called Laura Laura lock
something very close to that go Laurie you're saving eyes and she's green
I like the horse has socks on this is strong even the horse in Assassin's Creed brotherhood
it's over horse kill Laura Laura lie lock yeah Laura lie lock she helping us the fuck
oh they're helping us out so much for overall excuse me excuse me this is my horse go away
whoa whoa whoa okay he looks who increased there Winton no Winton
how does who put it up all the high council the chairs put it up sorry the Italian cheer
man put up wait no he's dead oh that's what the church used to do you could ask for refuge
even if wanted under certain terms he is refuge with that totem sorry he's calling upon the
Russian house a sigil oh let me keep my pants up juice calling upon the Russians
ballet dancers or something else I can tell you that much they're a different breed and
not know how they do it wait we're marked by the Russians with what's on our back I mean
I knew we are risky okay okay okay okay she come from she come from the lore is deepening
madam we're asking
anyone a life lane
zamae zamae zabae zabae
nope that as soon as she said stop dancing she completely collapses she's on the verge of
exhaustion what she is exhausted not even on the verge of exhaustion she's that's literally
what happened to me in 4k what the heck it's me I didn't realize they casted me
because of my wife Helen oh stay on oh stay on I didn't know you're in this I don't know I was
in either to be honest I don't really remember recording it oh we do see that move quite often
I think I like this I like the deeper lore notes I think this is a lore kind of video
in the castle by blowing back harder
are we about to get branded oh because the debt's been paid by Mo Maruski oh
we're on my butt cheek we're
ah right right right it's been five seconds geez geez geez
I'm not even some ace no not even a little burn cream little after son or anything geez
nah that's for Daniel geez it removes the family create I want to be branded by mom I think
yes I'm not sure I'd want to brand you like that that's very that's very mind broken I think that's
beyond the main break but I like I like the main break really you can ink without me I like that kind
of main break branding main break isn't it's I cannot provide the service some bait marks okay I'll
bait is
uh who are you
security something I can't read that fast
so
adjudicator from the high table
ah
uh
sure
i mean i don't know what you're gonna see
do we have a morgue
mommy leaving her stink on us oh my god you may do that for the convention i just mind
break you all with my nasty like gamer b.o
oh wait well
oh
whoa whoa whoa big when he's not getting in trouble
uh
excuse me
uh hold on the banks can be paused
we're going for the high table
you do not touch daddy winston
new target acquired
winston time to call in some friends we're all looking at the same problem here
i know winston's got the man and the communication
damn he's doing better than me the best i got is a pie hole
she traced us because of the gun billet no no
um
so
i thought i'm right you laughing her face
oh my god
we are we're in kaza blanko any kaza blankians
yeah sorry high tables just started yeah high table making enemies for her ass
i thought i was fast no no no no no the high table
okay arabic um
uh i was close enough i tried i tried i've forgotten it already
okay
that was turkish okay uh to say yes in turkish we say
yevet for some reason well because it's a different language not for some reason
yevet
thank you assassins creed revelations for teaching me that
i am the throne i am the senate
uh oh pause pause
what no schematters they didn't want to go straight uh stereotypical with a schematter
oh
okay okay okay okay boss man's coming in right boss man
yeah
and that belongs to you there you go you want to part a man with his weapon
oh he's serious
can i can i i'm gonna say something really dumb what country's kaza blanko and i assume it's a city
oh we need to see it it's in marocco ah okay okay marocco marocco marocco
oh sure okay i love the regional continentals i'm i'm here for it
absolutely adoring the regional continentals
uh thank you what happens next monkaes
i'm getting a little nervous i'm getting a little shaky
hello
oh she's got a wee a daughter and some poppers
oh monkaes easy boy easy
uh
i am
so
she's like jay a little bit nicer
uh
we had we had it done to us and as we've got it done to someone else
so
yes ma'am
oh i'm sorry okay sorry i don't pick up on social cues very well my apologies
so
yeah
Zero.
Wow.
You kidding me?
Oh
No dog trainer gender control that'd be interesting for a dome
It's like the most normal looking thing like doggy daycare outfit type stuff and she calls you her dog
Dog
Interesting may entertain that
Corporate woman she bees a corp. She's an office worker. That's where it fits all of it
Right, we're not in Casablanca anymore because it's renan
There are we
Ah
Neko days
Surprise go high that she be disease is a stream in today mercy if so
Little snippets mercy should be up soon to him and three four hours
my guys
Oh
So it's proper jam and I understand the plot but I'm proper jamming right now so shouldn't put this on I love
I'm gonna be Neko days
Oh
Okay, okay, okay weeps out weeps we're in but weeps out. Yeah, but it's a member stream though
So for any snippets who are a member or anyone else up below her might be a member of mercy modest
She is doing a membership stream and t-minus four hours. I repeat t-minus four hours
Zero might be live with a League of Legends. If I'm not whoa
What I miss whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa
Wait the Russians are being infiltrated
Wait
The yakuza got sent on the Russians cuz we gave passage fuck
No, oh the high table is gonna be in shambles in a minute
No, no, no, no, no madam madam
She gets to enjoy the show one last time until please do not hurt the dancers monk us
No, no, no, no, no
Well the dancers really do not stop for anything
Until madam's word
Fuck anyone the blood
Is she being oh she's gonna perish for are you joking?
Oh
See you in this table why not go hump it or something honestly go get married to this table. Oh 90 I saw that I
Pleasure legions to the high table of the United States of America, sorry, I don't know what is
I
Mama Maruski, are you okay?
Oh
Not the dogs have an ammo on them that's funny is anything the dogs have guns that come out like such
She'll live but yeah, what a painful punishment
You
Wait, who's he he's in Game of Thrones as well
Be nice to the popper
You
To train these dogs I imagine they worked a lot mmm a lot accused for the dogs I
I
Wonder if it's hard to get a dog not to look at the camera because babies and like toddlers and like child actors always
Look at the camera. They have to tell him to knock it off
You
Uh-huh
Yeah
Me are you sure
No
I
Have a little sniff
The elder
I'm sweating I'm getting nervous. I don't like this
No
Yeah
I
Ryan's bill you can see a the constellation from Scotland
Is that a joke oh
Yeah, we've been trolled or are we actually supposed to shovel off into the desert
You
No, not her dog
No
Oh
Oh.
Missed.
Fuck!
Deserved, deserved.
Yes! Yes! Get him! Get him! Take that foreskin! Arrgh!
Dog's having fun playing tug of war with this.
I hope he learned his lesson.
Okay, John, Wick and Sophia on the exact same page.
I'm sure when John was like, don't, he meant, yeah, go ahead.
Go ahead.
Oh! Kidding shot!
That dog mustn't have any hearing from the how loud those shots are, but...
Let's go, let's go.
Okay.
She's accurate.
Unconservative of the bullets.
I think he's gone after them. I think the fourth bullet and I'm really...
Whoa, you need to reload, darling. What's going on?
Nah, right, nah. Hold on.
You do not have that many bullets in the chamber.
Hold on, John Wick 1.
Writers?
Oh, shit.
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Hey!
The drill!
Whoa!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
She really trained them to go for the mints and turkeys on a man.
Holy crap, how many, bro?
Where's John Wick's KD? Like, be so for real.
Thousands, tens of thousands?
Yeah, get him!
Given that he hasn't died, infinite.
This feels like a time crisis.
Okay, okay, okay, did... did...
Poppers! Poppers!
We need a puppy
Okay, I don't I don't see GI but I've seen like those dogs. I get trained to do that like jump crazy. Hey
Oh
I pump can you did fantastic
Oh my god, these dogs are crazy
I
Think that dog got confused it's supposed to go in the same window as the other one, but it's fine. It's fine
Even up a tree can't save you from your boss getting bitten off honestly
Right, so are we unironically going on a constellation quest?
You tell me the elder of the high table is sitting about in the desert
Just hanging around the back satellite surveillance can't even find them
There you go poppers
Oh
Are you sure about that?
Oh, what bird tonight is tetanus, sorry the other one
I didn't see any Annie back on that point
I
Know the three fly on his suit I saw that don't think I didn't notice the fly on his suit
It's sucking up all them the moisture off of you every fun
Really
You
Really did we not just save her daughter and hide her and keep her safe
Oh
My god, we actually are just going on a random desert quest
My brother you are going to perish so quickly
And no drinking your pee in the desert doesn't work. You're filtering out urea, which is the
Like basically the straight poison your body can't handle it is why it's a byproduct
so no
Better drink your own
doesn't work
And at night in the desert I get sub below temperatures
Oh my god, there's gonna be a sandworm for dune coming out of nowhere in a minute
Okay
Well, this is where the quest ends clearly because we've just perished
Mummy can you do that too? Oh
You may spit water out and make you drink it
Seven days
No, no, no
No
Oh my god, right saws, but the yakuza is taking the mic. This is a soup kitchen
We feed the homeless fur just a human right shock and behavior honestly
Wait, is he is he gonna die? No, no, no, no, no, no wait, is Winston gonna die as well?
Oh my gosh
Oh, this cannot be
No, no, no
Come on pigeons have laser beams or something
Stun them stun them so we can shoot them. I don't want him to perish. Okay. Yeah, the seven bullets was mean, but
Oh
Come on
Oh, is this good or bad you're smiling is this good or bad?
I'll fuck off you
You
Eh
But he's gonna bleed out
Uh
But Mother Moselle got to live
Oh
He maybe could have survived maybe I don't know
I'd cut the gene. Please help us. Oh, thank god
When no one would touch Winston like that, but I didn't want him to oh
You
The elder
The elder above the high table is a dude in a desert
Uh, maybe he likes the humble life
Uh
It was a few things went wrong that could have gone better, okay
So
Oh
I better not start crying
Yes elder
Yes, what's it? Yes
We don't want that life elder
No
We want to retire
What are you gonna do John?
Oh, okay, okay, okay contract. No, you liar
You
My hands are on my head right now you're lying
Surely you meant like Winston Churchill the one in the casket and it's all a big misunderstanding not the
the Winston of the new york
again continental
Oh
What's gonna happen?
Oh, what what what what what what? Oh, we better get shanked
Yeah a chisel what do I do?
You
You want my pee pee skin
Fingernails no
Oh, well he's a part of the assassin brotherhood now. Jeez
No, his wedding finger
Oh
No
Is that our wedding band
No, no
Our wedding band, please tell me we nuke the high table to high heavens
And and john wick four
There's no way he's doing it in this one
Oh
My wedding band to my wife. Oh you sick man
You know you've actually got a decent set up for the middle of the desert i'm gonna be honest
Oh come on
Literally assassin created that
Our freaking wedding ring you have to be joking
What we're gonna do with Winston
Oh, please let this man heal at least
Right we're out of Casablanca. We're in new york city again
I assume we're getting attacked to hoy because the assassins are still on uh, uh, well there you go
It's bill and ben right on cue
Whoa white whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa yakuza. What's up?
Cherry bang bang
So cherry bang bang listen to baby metal be nice to me. Look at the atarashi gakko
See i'm a real atarashi
Please please let us live
Wait, what business what business i don't understand
Look we're a weeb
What business what do they want
The yakuza wants a 1v1 not right now. I don't know what we're gonna do with Winston though
Oh, hey you guys i'm out. Oh, okay. Well, it's not really a discussion is it it's not really a discussion
No one front of the wings no one front of the wings
You know that you know the rules
You
Oh, yeah, he just cgi'd right in front of us
Ah
Oh
He's got cgi as well get right we both have cgi on our side. That's right
Cji telephone hell yeah
Uh
Oh
That's rough
So we're
The continental rules still apply even though we were the one to break them
And now it's a race back
Fucking hell they're going a bit fast. I don't know cgi but come on mate
Oh
My god is Batman Arkham returns or something. I don't know that one Batman scene where they're under the bridge. I can't remember
You
Bruh
Oh
Okay, the numbers are in our favor the odds are getting higher
Well
I'm gonna be honest. I probably would have held onto the sword but that's just me
Well the rules apply now that you're officially pardoned
So now it's just the high table actors. We need to be worried about
The dark night. Yeah, wear a helmet dress for the slade not for the raid
I've never been on a motorbike before but apparently it's really exhilarating
Get inside get inside get inside
Get inside get inside
No, no, no, no
Uh-uh
Wow
Oh
Oh, no, but what we're gonna do about Winnie
Hey, why is the yakuza man following us in this is a private conversation. Hello
Um
I bet you you're one of them fanies at the urinal where you stand next to someone instead of like playing chinese checkers and
Fucking picking like the one that's like three away or something
The rule of the toilet is you're not supposed to sit next to someone
Don't move that make myself clear
What
Oh
He doesn't have a name or three fingers not there
Neko des
Oh
We pupper you still need to give you a name it's been a whole movie and you don't have a name yet
Surely by the end of this one we give that name
We're going for five languages
Yes
Don't know
I
By sir by sir by sir
Beak
Oh, I don't like this one the mr. Winston
I have really bad news, but i'm not really sure what the result of this is gonna be because
I don't think john would kill Winston. It doesn't make sense
I feel like something else has to occur
Mr. Winston
Imagine if he banged him for you
I
Knows
No
There has to be another way
I
Like this conversation no
No, no hold on
I was against the high table old buddy
No john
Come on
Or john wick married to his love Helen. Yes
Come on take on the high table
Okay, what belongs to you back come on this is it come on
Come on Johnny boy
Come on
No, I don't think I will
Yes
Come on
Oh
All rules are all gloves are off
All gloves are off you can kill
Oh
No, no, no, no
And I'm the gone Winston
Uh
No
Yes
Yes, yes, yes, yes
Oh, come on old boy Winston. Let's see the arsenal
Oh, let's see the arsenal
Oh come on sure was it
Or is it
Anything you desire
Oh, I'm excited. I'm excited
Yes, sir
So what you giving me light machine guns
Thank you for your recommendation my good sir
Oh
You
Oh, you're gonna need a hand those Virginia bitch
Whoa
Full male jacket
Whoa, please tell me he gets a really make to issue seen as well, please
Please tell me gentlemen gets a really make to issue seen
Really make sure you
Oh
Fuck them up Johnny boy sure is why they call you the Baba Yaga
Come on come on
I'm like smiling like an idiot right now
The concierge gets his scene because he's gonna be back shortly
I
Just a few Willy Pete's really to cover the area
Willy Pete's are smoke grenades
Although that flash part I didn't realize was a part of a Willy Pete. I'm not sure if it was a Willy Pete then
Oh, you're gonna get your comeuppance one way or another you mark big Baba Yaga's words
You go against Winston you go against Baba Yaga
Sharon the concierge Sharon my apologies
What's the dealio
Lights out
Just like how your lights are going to be out very shortly
Absolutely sir
Oh
Oh my god, that's all
The biggie man in green
And Sharon the concierge
Okay, we have a few on our side too
Oh
Fuck their armor is strong
Okay, okay, okay weak point weak point we've got one
You
Okay, no good not good not good
No, no, no, no, no, no
You
My eyebrows are so framed right now
Well it takes so much to take one down
You
Okay, Sharon's coming in
Shaiz
It's a lot of ammo
I'll take that I'll take my chances without over a pistol II
I like Winston looks on like a pro father. He's like, yeah, you get on keep keep at it sons
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, let's try that again. Shall we
What
Okay, okay, okay
You
That blast back
Yeah, that's the only thing we're shotguns ain't got much to him
Yeah
His butt's like slammed on that creator a greater thing
You
Quad loading I didn't mean to do that
Winston is literally stronger during Elden Ring. How dare you say something so true yet so controversial
You're doing great reeflings keep it up me with my crossbow in the corner
Oh, let's go for a swim
I feel like it still has enough oh doesn't the chamber get flooded
So it doesn't shoot or am I going crazy and I just made that up
Oh
I think the blood is an indication
Oh my gosh, give it a rest you kids
What's up, dude
Hell with the John Wick
Hey, I'm with the John Wick. I ain't got no time for your words. I couldn't give less of a
You
Where did he go he said hocus pocus of your focus point, I don't know
Ouch
Whoa
Okay
Oh my god, I need some help oh concierge
Can you give give me a second to breathe?
Oh my god, how are they doing that?
Uh
What did you do that for
Alpha foxy, oh
You can't even see the thing
The enemy
It's truly a means
Bro, no human body can
Knife so sharp it's cut in glass are blades like that other than obsidian even possible
Man Winston's gonna be so mad at the renovation price
Oh
It's not over
Go upstairs pop that samurai or armor on do a few Elden Ring rules and you're good to go John. Come on, Johnny boy
My money's on you
Let us I bug
Uh
That's not good
Oh indonesian wow, I'm the
Oops, I thought it was your cursor, but it's not
You
Huh is this a joke what?
Let him get up let him get up let him get up
He's telling a ting his bell off all right, okay
Oh
His whip and lung now watch me with
Hey
Oh
Don't kick me in the head
I
Actually kind of like these
fights because it's like it shows
Obviously it's to show like the desperation more than like a perfectly choreographed fight type thing
So I just don't like it. I don't mind it. Sorry. Not that. I don't like it. I do like it
Like I like that is messy. I like we're like fucking scrambling
Rather than these like perfect executions off the back every single time
And we're almost there I think
Now stop it stop hitting me stop hitting yourself stop hitting yourself just can populate
Oh john winks like wait, that's all is tiana Reeves
Are they done
Oh
No, well it's been a pleasure
I don't know do you want to ask them
Oh, okay. Yeah. Yeah, stay down stay down stay down. It's all good. Okay, you're next
Oh
There you go region
He's like six foot one six foot two
185 oh, he's as tall as a zero
Thank you
And yet I persevere
You
He only wants to win via sword
So it's I'd be scavenger in for like one pistol ammo. That's all I need
Are you
Is he a john wick wannabe
He set it up so john had to go up the level on the RPG
Actually, yeah, he did what the fuck final boss is waiting for you at the tower make sure you heal up first
You
Really wanted to be like me so badly
I
I like the score marks detail
You
Easy come on come on big johnny boy just whack him
I'll let this
But goodness sake
All right, I was gonna say we've been at this fight for you just come on
Let's wrap up now wrap it up wrap it up. I want to continue with the plot was happening
Well Winston wrap it up. You've been at this for a bit too long. Oh
Are we going to be fingies?
Sorry, mate. I wasn't really the plan, but I mean I guess what would happen
Oh
Come right. Okay. Yeah, I was gonna say wrap it up. Wrap it up. Come on. I want to see what happens with Winston
Come on like we've seen combat for like 20 minutes now
Okay, all right, we win. Yep, there we go
Don't get me wrong. I love a good combat scene, but as soon as it starts to go a little bit too far
I'm like, come on. Let's go let's go into the plot
Okay, what's the deal?
Hi dad. Hi son
Oh
Oh curious
Noted
Thank you concierge
You not only do you serve the guests, but you serve death to those who need
I'll give our lie down buddy lie down wrap it up wrap it up
Yeah
No, well
No, I don't think I can get to you a hospital in time, but uh
I'll just let you do your thing
Uh
Oh
Yeah
With friends at sea
Oh
Farley, okay, do you talk in French means badly?
Yeah
Yeah, he's he's got a portfolio, bro
Wait, wait, whoa, whoa, hold on
You
Uh
Let him go run free
Oh
Hello
Well played
Where's there a crash mat down there that I didn't see or
Huh
What
You
Come on buttercup
Oh my god, was there a crash?
Yes
Oh I feel like shit. Oh, yeah
With friends like please
Yes, yes
Yes, yes, yes
Please
Yes
Like I want vengeance
Mm-hmm
Yeah
I'm gonna take a look
We're doing it. We're going against the high table
Oh my god, we're doing it. Yeah
John's becoming a real reflin type of put down the high table wink wink
Okay, that's gonna be our codename the high table
I'm real
Oh my goodness, ah, I'm loving this
Oh my god, are you to and we in part five isn't even out
But we're gonna have to watch part four. We have part four now
Healyberry wait, isn't Healyberry an X-Men?
John wakers against the world
Oh my gosh, I'm loving this. Sorry. I completely forgot to do wines during that entire like segment
Oh, she is she is she is oh my god. We're going against the high table replays
Yatta, she was the Casablanca lady
Oh my gosh, we're doing it. We're doing it. Oh my gosh
Okay, let me change it the title to four
And then we'll get a quick break
So I can
Uh, right pause and then go next one
You know like next
That's it and pause
Does that display? Yep, it does. What? How long is this movie?
Okay, I'm going to heavily recommend
Um, everyone get a snack and a stretch and a toilet and a
Yes, uh, I did not realize
How long this one is
So maybe chapter five doesn't play off of four because this is so long
Maybe we do all of the high table in one go
Because for a three-hour movie, I feel like you can take out a lot of
First the lady in the cloak the cloak goes first surely surely
Well, what do we do about Winston? Do we understand that Winston didn't actually want to kill us?
Or was he forced to? Is he still an ally? I'm not really sure what because he wasn't like
Oh, yes, I will destroy John Wick right now. So I'm a bit uh, a bit curious about
What Winston's arc is I keep bringing out those gloves, but I'm not trying to do a boxing match
Uh, right, we're gonna find out we're gonna find out no spoilers
Please the only time I ask for no hand-holding and no spoilers is we're gonna watch John Wick 4
And I've never seen it. Uh, I don't think I saw it there. I don't really recall any of that
I'm so glad the concierge got a little bit of a scene
Um, I wish there was a bit more badassery coming from him
I feel like the concierge is like the the doting kind of gentle until it's like time to call in the arms
like that kind of thing
um
He shot my bulletproof vest, so I don't know if he meant to keep him alive
I feel like he would have known he was alive
But like y'all didn't put like a little crash mat down there for him
You know, you could have could have moved it away by the time she went down the elevator
And that's all I'm saying. Okay, the lift takes you know, I'm not saying you've got the fastest lifts in the continental
But a little crash mat wouldn't have gone amiss. Uh, definitely would have helped out. Um
But hey ho
We are alive reefing willing is alive and reefing has been sent into take down the high table
Which I'm very curious to see how this goes. Um, I also didn't mention
We're officially in the 30 thousands for our wanes
um, I believe a
A lovely reefing has done the maths and they said that my wanes in my bank if I do them
I am 99
uh, we are at 36,000 so
They're
Maybe if I can get it down to
20,000
Oh, I don't know if I have time for 20,000
Maybe then tomorrow's endurance stream. We might actually do it
Um, what level of cooking am I now? I am 90 um 100 xp off of 91
Um, but we are cooking by gas. We're getting there. We're getting close
um
Right, I am going to get a cup of tea. I'm going to get some food. I'm going to get a few snacks
I'll be a wee bit longer. I'm going to take a toilet break. Um, I just need to tinkle just because again
I highly recommend you do it as well if you're watching john
A wick four the one reefing that's called john right now is just constantly
Oh
In his chair john john john john john johnny jonathan big john zoe
big johnny boy
Everyone's like going to start once we get marshmallows back
Everyone's going to start sending messages that secretly have their name in it and hopes I say like the main name
I don't know if anyone was called sam, but we watched um
Um
Transformers and the main guy's called sam wit wiki. So I was like sam sam sam
Um, but I find it fun that like I might there's a there's a chance. I might like say your name just by just by chance
Yeah, that john literally mean currently legally changing my name to john
Approximately 1.5 of people in the us are named john or some variation of that. Wow. That's a big number
If that uh, but you guys okay, okay
Yeah, yes, right. Okay. I I'm going to go quickly get some snacks. I'm going to go for a
I'm going to make a tea and
We're getting there though
We're getting there
Honestly, I don't know if you can speedrun crafting crafting's been I was interested in crafting
But I maybe would do that in my own time. I'll maybe not uh make you guys watch crafting. I think the runescape streams
Um, I'm definitely happy to take a bit of a break
After other than doing questing together ones. I don't mind the questing. Those are those are fun as anything
um
But yes, please get a snack. Please go for a tinkle. I'm going to do the exact same
I'll be a couple of moments and then we'll jump straight back into the john wick. Shall we?
Crafting is quickish, but it costs a lot of money. You'll never guess how much money I have in my runescape bank account
Okay, give me a minute. I'll be back uh to make a cup of tea and a pee and you should definitely stretch your legs
Okay, because we have been sitting for a while
You
Are you squiddin me right now
Are you squiddin me right now would you do another members karaoke stream in the near future
You
Sorry my
Fuck that's so bloody loud honestly
The desktop music is separate and it's so loud when you're not signed in. Oh my god. That was blaring
Wow
Thank you. Doomsday damn for the tip and do lay lover via lure for the five
Would you do another members karaoke stream? Absolutely. Yes. Um
I think I have like
I actually don't think it'll be a problem all from my voice because I've already worked it to be honest
the what right so
I've permanently damaged my voice, which is fine. It's not a big deal
but the actual
The actual
positive of it is that
I can keep going now if that makes sense now that is damaged like I can keep going
And the damage was just singing which doesn't really make much of a difference to me because I don't like I don't have an interest like
Some vtubers like absolutely have like a full interest in singing for me personally. I couldn't give less about
Um
Mum is back. Yes. Oh no the runescape. Yeah
Still down runescape. You're stuck with me
Um, right. I've got a cup of sorry. You didn't see that. I've got a cup of tea
Um, I actually didn't see any snacks that I was interested in so I literally have tea cola and water
um
To last me through these three hours. I keep forgetting to boil new eggs so I can just grab them for stream
but
It's fine. It's fine. Um as for tomorrow's stream
It's a 50 50 if it gets changed for something else
I don't know if I can do two back-to-back endurance streams without absolutely annihilating my health
I'll see what kind of sleep I get
But I'm just warning you now. I don't know if we're gonna be able to finish off the wines tomorrow. Um
because I might be
um
Just doing something smaller because I've got a few things to do for the girls. Um, they've been absolutely fantastic. So the
The editors that work for veal were um, they're getting put to work
We're gonna see what the kind of price return
Etc is and then
Yeah, don't be surprised if you see a hell of a lot more consist
Short consistency now that the the dust is settled. Um
We currently have four clippers. I have my own personal clip editor
Um, but I might hit get her to do some her names are rissa. Hi rissa. I doubt your your but
Um, she's such a nerd. She plays dnd and she's like oh my dnd cancelled
I can do some more editing for you and I'm like, oh, that's so adorable
Are you sure you want to like not take the day off or whatever?
But um, yeah, rissa's really cool. I like her. Um, and she's Australian. So it makes me even cooler. Um
I might I'm gonna see if I can get one more clipper on board. Um
Cause
Uh, I'm starting to want to get highlight reels of the girls
And shorts coming out a bit more consistently
I'm gonna aim for three shorts per week and see how that works out because obviously
You guys have been fantastic clipping the girls. By the way, I see sent me
I like instructed the girls on how to how to show me the clips that they want turned into a short on youtube
And I see came through she was like scrawny. I'm so sorry for all this
I like do not be silly. You have literally like saved me so much time
You've given me such high quality clips. Like don't be silly. So thank you special. Thank you to literally anyone who is
mucking about clipping
Like any funny ha ha's of any of the girls you help out so much with these shorts that we're gonna start making and posting and all that jazz
like mercy, um
Had like a hilarious short. I don't know if you've seen it. Oh, sorry. My cats are going nuts. Um
I just fed them. So they're probably going to actually not
Breaking my door. Um
Mercy had this like hilarious short
Someone asked her like, oh, are you going to do a cooking stream? And she told the story about a time
She freaking was cutting upside down with a knife and I'm like, oh my god
I thought like I thought we were kind of memeing that mercy is like the pawn one
No, mercy is the pawn one
Like it was the most it was the funniest short I've ever seen in ages. I absolutely adore it. So don't be afraid to like
I think if you click subscriptions, you can like scroll down like two and then it shows like shorts of who you're subscribed to
So don't be afraid to like look at whatever the girls are like posting if you've subscribed to us all
Which I know you have subscribed to us all haven't you?
Yes, good
Let's see if you want to get 99 crafting at some point the typical trading method is minus 30 million
I wonder what the time is in crafting up
I'm getting addicted a little bit to runescape, but not as addicted to balochro balochro. Uh, yes. Yes. Good. That's all I'd hear
I demand
unification, okay
That's funny. Like bro the pawn levels are so high upside down now
Literally a yandere that doesn't know how to night hold a knife properly is the funniest story
I think I've ever fucking heard in my life
Um, and it was edited so well like that editor like was above and beyond he does fantastic. Um
40 hours. Oh shit. How much is cooking? How many hours have I put into cooking?
Well, the first stream didn't count because I was getting distracted mucking about with you
We were doing questing so the first runescape stream doesn't actually count
Um
I wasn't able to clip yesterday stream. No, no, no, don't worry. Don't worry if you can't do it
But like for any like literally for anyone who goes back and is like, oh that moment made me blow air out of my nose
A little bit faster. Hmm. It helps out so much. It really does. Uh, azer gave me a bunch as well. I am gonna
Um, see if I can get some going for sheebie. I was having problems with sheebie shorts. Um,
I think I mentioned this the other day. She's so boobalicious that um
YouTube basically limited pretty much everything which sucked. Um
I couldn't put advertise like you can put youtube ads to like make her
Like their shorts show up in the algorithm more, but because she'd be so boobalicious
I wasn't having it. Although Azura's it let through and I'm like, I think we can all agree. Azura's got bigger oranges than
Sheepsters, so I'm not really sure how they determine it one minute
They're discriminating against Azura the next minute. They're like, ah, that's fine
Cookin's 30 hours. Why am I taking so long then honestly?
I find I tend to clip a lot more when watching vods. Yes, especially
Thank you to any vod watchers that like go back and clip or timestamp like funny moments as well
I am able to see that on my end. Um, but I have asked the girls to take on that responsibility because uh
If you didn't know most VTuber agencies don't
Actually create like thumbnails or they tell their girls to like make shorts
Themselves or out of pocket and I'm like no if you guys just give me the clip
I'll send it off to a clipper and pay for that and then I'll pay for promotion as well like
um
It's quite outrageous what some of these VTuber agencies ask of their talent in my opinion
But and that's just how it is. So hopefully over time things can change like, um
Sock VTuber agency looks like it's going to be different, which I'm very happy and excited about um
I
um
I'm very happy to see the rise of new agencies and learn the behind the scenes. Um
Obviously, we've been incredibly friendly with the yumi plus girls and the behind the scenes
I got to learn a bit more about them and I am
Uh, very happy with the direction they're going. So I'm happy to obviously muck about with them. Um
And hopefully the girls find prosperity under prosperity prosperity prosperity not prosperity
I think that's a different word. Uh prosperity, uh, pros the good one the good one live long and prosper that one
I yes live long and prosper for the girls and um, I'm very excited for what the future holds for yumi plus. Um
I do genuinely think these kinds of VTuber agencies, uh
definitely
more of a
What's
More of a more and poor vibe. I think is very nice
Is posterity boobs or something? I don't know as there has more but there's more ropes on yeah
I mean it pays for itself investment is visibility
Um
Yes, and no the reason I say no is because the books haven't been done for the first month of peeler yet
And I don't know if I've I've spent like way much in like advertising watch along. There's a few hidden things as well
That was paid for
Um, the shorts are being paid for so I need to do I need the books to be done
I don't do the books because obviously I'm number dyslexic
Um, I'm waiting on the bookkeeper to do their part once the first of july rolls around
And then I'll be able to see what the agency earned
And then that means I can maybe talk about my donathon goals. We're a bit far away. We're still
We're still not even clear. We're you know, october's my donathon
But as I said, my donathon is related to the agency. It's not related for myself
Whereas the girls donathons are related to potentially moving out or doing more content or having the availability to do certain things. Um
Posterior is your rear. Wait put posterior
Why is that?
Oh, we're also gonna have to watch monty python at one point
And before actually we ran out of money collapse. Oh, no, I
For me personally, um from what I've seen
No, the company is not running out of money. Uh
I
When it comes to ROI, which is return on investment. Uh, yeah, let's just say I'm no worries
You guys have been incredibly supportive incredibly generous
Um, the patreons are popping off the merchandise. Thank you for anyone that buys from uwu market because that
profit margins all go to the talent. It is the we
We vealor do not get cut. We it doesn't even go through our hands. They own like the accounts and everything
um
And we hopefully have some very exciting news soon to him. Uh
Posterior meaning behind posterity meaning past. Well, I got it completely wrong
Yes, we're gonna watch the life of brian because you freaking fanies keep taunting me with fondle of bism
And it's like, is there something wrong with the way I say
fondle of bism
She has a what she has a yandere, you know
karam
Karambit
Basically is how that's gonna go. Um, so you guys are so done when we watch that together. Um, absolutely done
Um, because Lucas is fondle of bism
Look, it was a good name. It wasn't a bad name. I actually like the name
I don't know. Maybe I'll I'll get her to have a halloween outfit
um, and then like she has a tag on her head that says fondle of bism
and
Just as long as we don't watch the holy grail. Wait, what's wrong with the holy grail?
Have I seen that? I think I've seen
life of brian
with my family at christmas actually
Uh, hey, it's karambit herself. Hey, and you come and you come fondle of bism jen to strawney 365
Look, it was a good concept that now I remember why the numbers the numbers are because I wanted to stream for one year in a row
Barring absolute death. Okay
Holy grail is fine. Is it not huge tracks of land mods kill this roofling. Wait. Oh, no, what happened?
Oh, the movies were overrated
Oh
What wins that goes oh, oh 91 91
Always look on the bright sidey life
Whistle whistle whistle whistle whistle
Remember that time that mercy can't whistle
Remember that time I clipped mercy not whistling
Remember that time I'm getting a short produced of mercy of being unable to whistle
It's coming out soon
She just doesn't know it
Um
You know what you know, you're adorable moment on stream where you try to whistle and you went
Uh, I may or may not I'm getting that turned into a short because I find it absolutely adorable. It's the cutest thing I've ever seen
Uh, yeah, so you may or may not be taunted just a tiny bit for your whistle
Oh, now she does mercy's in shambles. So john wick though. Yes, right john wick part four for those of you
Who are uninitiated? I say that as if I didn't literally get initiated two minutes ago
We are following the plot of john wick
Now this man has came from very
Far away in terms of he wanted to give up the assassino life because he found the love of his life
Helen who sadly was taken away by fate itself due to illness
Um, and then loads of things happened and now we're taking down
The high table is everyone ready to play
Part four john wick
Get your seatbelts on
Uh, because when I say go we are going for it on the count of three
three
two
one
go
John wick four
Let's find out what happens next and for any snippets who may be lurking
Mercy's
Membership stream is in t minus two hours. I repeat t minus two hours
Uh, right here we go
Oh, the upgrade of it. No, they updated
They updated the freaking intro. I knew I knew it looked old as anything
I was like, bro, I could probably do better myself. Oh my god. That's so rude though. I'm sorry
I don't I don't mean to be rude like that. I'm a bad person
I forget how quick these movies like jump in
Okay, all we know is we're going against the high table
You
Yes, such a good laugh
Wait, they're burning the suit whoa
You
He got paid $20,000 for that line
I just made that up. I'm sorry if you believe that I just made that up
Yeah
It was like that chicken din too
Where she showed up for like five seconds
I didn't say anything and they had her in the promo and it was like, bro
You didn't even have a lick of a sentence in the movie
I know we're not watching done. It's pretty decent though
Source my dreams momy
Oh, we're going to
The that one
Oh my god, we're watching the mummy
I've downloaded the wrong film. All right. Okay. The mummy didn't
Okay, they didn't go like this. They didn't go like this. M. O. Tep. We're coming for you
There's four men, but only one is riding the horse of the apocalypse
I
Downloaded the mummy. Oh, that's pretty good. Whoa. Is that the elder?
Wait, we're going for the elder right off the bat. No, this is true
You
My mouth is a gate
We're going for the elder right off the bat. Oh this movie is wrapping it up
Oh
Give me my finger back. It's a bit too late. I think
Uh
Yes
Why wait what
You
My god every movie they all say oh, you're still the same person fuck you give me my ring back
Isn't death yes, and you and you're sorry you're making it too obvious
Yeah
Are you sure about that?
John Cena
What a start to the movie the elder of the high table first
Oh
What a star
Oh, we're burning it all down
Whoa, whoa, whoa. Oh, we're gonna be Winston. Let's sort out this nasty business surely
Uh
No, you're not who is you
You'd we think he's gone too
Uh
I
Harbinger and harbinger
It
He just got it back
Uh
What the fuck is that for
What and they're gonna new kit
They got a fusion reactor or something some uranium and that's okay. So what's going on?
Oh
Jerry and executioner
Oh, come on Johnny boy you wouldn't part an old man with his hotel now
You
Did we mess up tails wrong it said harbinger that's a that's a harbinger
Oh Winston's not going down with the ship stop
Oh
Please do not start the movie I didn't cry the last movie I don't think
Such evil architecture with the rich the timer
One of the friends are the enemy
Why do we eyeball switching is it okay?
You
Is he got lisp or is he just French and the refuge
Because
Both both pick pick a struggle be French or have a list pick one
Hey bro bro lift up bro. You're making a squeak
We
By my stomach just fired if you heard that
Whoa, excuse me
I mean Stonehall sorry
I
Sorry there's birds on the roof if you can hear that I keep feeding the birds and well, I don't want to sell
Huh
There's a one little incident
Um, are we about to be shot
Concierge
You
What
Oh
Oh, you're gonna regret that you French fuck
No, mr. Concierge, no
No, fuck I'm crying in the fourth one
No
Oh Winston do everything you got
Oh
Brimstone and hell fire Winston, you know the drill
Oh my god, why?
Why?
Get your fucking piano out of this goddamn scene fuck off
What
We're in France, I guess the enemies really are French
I've forgotten the name of that place but it's that touristy shit
That was his last performance as well
Hey, it's an Irish real fan those dogs are like uh for like rich people mostly I guess
See you and you ya bam. These are all bams. See you wait. Is that mr. Chow from hangover or am I just being really bad right now?
No, that doesn't sound like him
No, that's uh, donnie yen
Bit of cocaine
You
Yeah
Is this a troll?
Are we being trolled right now are they sending a guy a blind guy to go kill John Wick?
Um
No, wait
What is he today poison him maybe
Are they purposely making it unfair for him?
That don't make fun of the cane he's a go
Uh-huh
Are we getting one more ally
Oh, we're in Tokyo
Minasan
Oh, hi yo, minasan
I've forgotten that meme where it's the guy in the water and he dubs over minasan. I've completely forgotten
We're in Osaka
Oh
The music's guilty
Okay, maybe this is the yuka yukas yukas. Oh freaking the sick the word for gang members in japan
That video game that video game
That's not our dog. No someone else's dog
Yeah
Aw
Whoa don't put cards in your mouth. That's how you get germs
Hi, bubba, you're so kawaii
Whoa
Did I read that does he a billion am I going crazy?
No million is going off wait, okay, I didn't read that fast enough
18 million okay, my brain read a billion I was like a bit much
Oh
Because of the news
Hi, hi, hi, that was actually kind of good not gonna lie
Oh
You
She's scared
What
You
Wait what okay, okay, okay, I get it. Okay, I get it. I was confused but I get it now
I was being a dumb dumb
She wanted to father to our date because he's a busy man. Okay, I get it
Oh
For fuck's sake him or stereotypical can you get sumo's garden the door relax
Stereotypes relax relax next was going to be a purple streak in the hair somewhere come on
He's up on the stereotypes on you
Uh not quite
All the second
Relax snowflakes, it's called dark
Replace the H and heart with an F relax snowflake it's called
Yeah
Wow
Oh
Oh, it's a good teapot see how the water wasn't spluttering out. That's a good teapot well well worth its money
And they think John will
You
Missing so may my excuse me go men are sorry
Well, we actually look healed up for once
It's like it's the first time we've not had a massive grease on us
Oh
The marked him out why
You
Um, are we about to have a shoot out?
Oh
Fuck they're already here
Why isn't the tail runescape
It
Look like sense, okay, I bet you I bet you you see it run scape in your accent
Well, I'm just trying to play some run scape today. Uh, we're gonna level up some cooking a bit of run scape
Go ahead get ready
He lost his way too
Trima trauma
Oh piss
Uh, are we about to escape with her hold on are we about to
They have an adoptive daughter
No, no, we can't sorry we have to destroy the high table. We can't be your like adoptive father, okay
I think maybe we protect her and drop her in a safe house possibly it's the only way I can see them
You
No
Oh
Are we actually gonna get beaten up by a blind man
Old friend
Is he a common voice actor I feel like he is
He sounds like Genji and shit, but it might just be my ignorance
Alive
You
Oh fuck off
Went already in position
You leave me no choice
I don't like this
You
Are you telling me they don't have access to guns
Yeah, we playing like Civ 6 right now and Japan hasn't developed weaponry yet. They're just like on max on culture
I'll come on
Reinforcements
You
John needs the bones
We'll have the saccharin tree isn't so sweet anymore
Oh
It was splits though
Now we have the badass lady on earth say oh well we had it with a Halle Berry
Oh
That was a very unique
Uh
Honestly means fuck if I'm gonna die I want a nice bowl of chicken ramen in this belly
Is
Anyone remember when they the first movie was really realistic when I was not me you win some you lose some
Oh my god
Bro bro bro
This this our arrows are Pearson
Oh, it's Hennessy in the noodles
Is that a blowdar
You
Can I say something really controversial and it's not very nice
I really hope this enemy is defeated quickly because the gimmick is pretty bad
I know that's not nice, but that gimmick is a bit too strong
I hope he perishes quickly
I swear if he makes it through the three hours
Like I get it don't get me wrong
But
You don't like the idea of a blind man killing everyone. Yeah, and like being able to sense arrows going past. Yeah, I have dead in it
I really enjoyed
The other concepts they put forward, but this is a bit
Like the old sensey thing she hates the school of blind fury. Wait, is that a movie or something?
Bro, he's literally using the force
Okay, I like the ding dong aid assists, but
If you're gonna tell me there's a fight between him and John Wick like come on
He's a Jedi in another life honestly
No, he's just tough. Okay
You see his toes out if he's tough
Ouch stuntman, I hope you got paid well for that
Stranny hates blind people. No, I do not hate blind people
I think you're doing awesome
Did you know that um
blindness like it to get uh diagnosed with blindness and
Over 50% of like the blindness diagnosis still have some vision. It's not like straight up like see nothing blindness
like a lot of those who are diagnosed with it still have some sort of like
light
perspective and
and
Extreme prescription that kind of thing. It's not necessarily like straight up knee nothing going on at all
So yeah, just thought you should know
There's also degenerative um
Ones where you're born with sight but over time you become blind as you go on
Wait mommy japan discovered guns. Sorry. I'm getting I'm getting too much into facts about the population and stuff
I
Me are steaks stop it
Bruh
Let's see got her hair is I love that design though you yanking it
Hard to hypnotize someone when they're blind. Damn you got me. She's ice-claiming this man. Oh, no
Wait, they're gonna kill her
It was it was just a major organ. It's fine
Yes
As you will it
Oh
Sue wait is this also mean like
Because obviously that game's called also like do your best or am I being an idiot?
No gambates do your best
I
Like how the enemy design have only masks for this region as well as like another nod to the culture and to appreciate it
Gambate
You
Num I twat myself on num chucks. I just know that for a fact
The armor is amazing on the enemies
I think you've gotten
You
Wait, what day is it for America is it Saturday or Friday right now for America?
Friday, okay good. Sorry. Okay tomorrow the highlights for debut. Okay
Thank you. Thank you. I was like, oh wait a minute
Wasn't I supposed to have the highlights for debut coming out on Saturday?
And I was like, uh, what day is it for you guys? Smile
Okay, okay tomorrow the highlights of debut come out
On everyone's channel. I will do that when I wake up after my sleep
You
Don't do the fancy whipping around it's not that hard to not get hit
I don't know. I feel like I'd be like that with a whip as well
Like those kind of weapons that can horribly backfire
I'd probably have like the worst scar on my face after whipping the crap out of myself
And because whip scars don't heal
Just a simple swinging trapping it under your arm against
Requires a high dexterity score
I have like the only thing I have going for me is luck
And endurance these are the only two attributes if you had to like make a player card of me
Luck and endurance is the only two things and it has gotten me so far. I have zero perspective
Um, like I have no idea what's going on around me. No not perspective. What's the perception? That's it
I have no idea what's going on around me. I've not now charisma possibly got some points in charisma
and
Oh
Oh, please tell me this face done in like three sayings. Come on
You
Wrap it up wrap it up come on
I've dead man. I'm not feeling this. I'm not feeling this section
A gunfight with a blind guy really
In my solitude wrap it up like let's go to the next one
He does what to the gun
If you don't have subtitles on it says caulk's gun and it's spelt that way
So that was a terrible joke
I
Literally just beat him by throwing something a little to the right and then one pop and game, you know gg
Come on
Stop talking you're giving away your eco location
Oh, I'm I'm gonna start spanking the dirt is script writers for this one. I have to admit
Man cling clang and on fucking stuff in the room and you're like, oh gee. I wonder where he is cling clang cling clang
Oh, okay nice one John
I wish Johnny would caulk my gun
I'm gonna play that fucking ps4 horror game where you don't breathe
You
Hey
Friend or fool
What
You
Friend or fool what
Neither
You
20 million
That was a lot of money
I
I'm starting to understand why this movie is three hours long. I think we've legit had no
Fucking plot for like the last 30 minutes it's all been fighting
Hey
Hi friend, please
You
What are you a fan
Please don't set the dog on me. I'd appreciate that
I was talking about the cowboys though
What he just wants the bounty until it's bigger and then he can disappear
Yeah, damn
It's honey
So the bounty keeps growing. Oh, I want them to live
Please let them live
No
Modes eliminate this blind man
Oh, no, no, no, come on
He's gonna die right in front of his freaking daughter
Oh
How did they make these action films so sad
Modes take this man's dry row away
Actually about one person probably understood that reference
Dry row is the disability paycheck you get if you're legally like disabled or the the doctor
Deems you unfit for work. So that was a very poor joke, but
I just want this guy gone. I don't like the plot surrounding him. I don't I'm sorry. I said it
Please John Wick pop out of the water and just
And let it be done
Oh
Just let them win
Like one old man, you're totally gonna win this there's your chance this old man is winning the stank fight
You
All right, I was most stomach as you heard that
What
Is he not bleeding out
What I don't understand
Wait so he could have survived the injuries
And he was gonna leave the daughter alone
I'm not even crying from upset. I am getting frustrated now
Uh
Can we can can we get timestamp when blind man die dies
I'm gonna say the script rewires are definitely different in this bloody movie because the
The vibe and the change is
So
Well, it seems like she's gonna get him at least later date
Wrap it up
I'm not spoiling it
That last indication and the shot made it seem like she will be the reason the man perishes at least
So my i'm allowed to predict or is that really annoying if the person predicts a street like the how the movie's gonna go
I'm uh, yes to predictions or no to predictions
You
Can always predict okay, just don't answer
Because of that last shot being like i'll be waiting for you
What's gonna happen is wait, wait, wait, they're actually becoming a jewel stop. I guess that the star
I
Was gonna say she'll slip in just as he's about to lose the fight and perish the blind man
Kane
Oh
This is a very unlikely jewel it's not looking good
Or I will yeah, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay
You
I couldn't even imagine what's recent through her head right now. She literally warned her dad at the start
Oh, they never got to go on the father door date
Oh with friends like these moment
Oh no, they're hosting a funeral for the hotel
You
Benevolence I love that word benevolence
I miss my dad is though
Oh for the concierge, oh yes for the concierge my apologies
I
Misses fringe put on
You need wait inside outside fucking what?
Oh, this is some rich people stuff even I haven't seen before and inside outside little horse freaking
Area what
Make the pony do the Crip walk come on, you know you want to
Yeah
Rich people hobbies honestly
Here he is the old man didn't like that yet the younger blood did
I
Periwinkle, okay, we'll give the dog that dog's called periwinkle
You
Man's just in it for the money straight up we like that honestly
What
Okay, what
Ooh, I like those words
You
What I don't see the scar in the back of your hand
Oh
I'm not looking sorry
I didn't understand. I thought he was gonna put it through the hole for some reason and I was like the knife handles too big
I didn't I didn't understand. I'm sorry. I'm not looking
Oh, I can't handle that
Oh, okay
Wait, that's how the guy became blamed because he made a deal
Crazy
Wow
Is this high-class entertainment watching horses do a little circle she
Oh
No, we actually are at the funeral
Sharon
Wait, we've had to meet big Winnie
Winston how's it hanging surely a little bit bygones be bygones
You
Uh
No
You
Sorry
He's gonna
You
Will destroy it from the inside out if we become an appointed member
I'm a bit slow
I do apologize I'm a bit slow in this one RuneScape progress 91 we're 150 off of 92
No, he's not joining he's gonna wage us freedom with the one we want to get out
So we're not trying to destroy it anymore
Thank you well
You
Good can we have one normal interaction holy like
What did they put glitter on this man's suit what is going on?
I don't think I've ever seen a glitter suit in my life
Uh
We either just made an ally or we just made an enemy
No an enemy, okay
In me
Well, we've got ourselves in a little bit of a situation
Oh
Really Katya any other Russian name
Oh my
You
Man's running out of oxygen he needs his brain cells come on
Well he's already in brain start and brain damage stage so
We need a bit too long on that one 20 seconds is enough to do it
You
Hmm
Please don't beat me up, mr. Klaus
Bro
Hey, can you go kill this person? Yeah, sure. Oh, but let me just tie you to bits first. Okay. Yeah, that makes perfect sense
So I think I'm turning into a little here right now
Oh my god, we're playing bell true
You
Or a buckshot really. Oh, did you know buckshot relates doing multiplayer? I might be able to go against you guys
Wait, he doesn't
They really said I am group
Honestly me when I get too excited on a
Oh give it a rest
You
Wait, so we don't even have passage or anything
His wife
By showing up
Whoa
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, I did not expect that
I
Thrunden mine Vroiden
Oh
This is the most bizarre poker game we're about to have what is the sack are gonna show up the the chick as well
Oh my god, hey, what's going on man?
Are we about to have the most bizarre poker game of our lives
Is it not gonna be on right now, okay?
You
So we actually are gonna just no
But at least let me shuffle the cards because I don't know how to fix them
You
And we're literally paying Belcher
Right, I'm not gonna pause I'm gonna get kind of cool. Okay, I'll literally be on bellows
Okay
Okay, okay, we know what high cards are we don't fill houses are you squiddin me right now
I
I didn't even mute. Thank you for hyper, but bro, I shouldn't even go
Canicle
Right, we've got two doubles
That's like twit
He just has very bad vision because of the scars
Holy shit royal flush
You
Oh
Forgive you're gonna have to come together
Um
You guys want to become allies
You guys want to become allies for like a second
What
Sure
Okay, hold on a minute, I might have been a little heasty I will admit I'm an absolute follower
No, I'm not the flashbang
I actually really like when the enemies become allies hold on they might redeem themselves
The movie might have redeemed itself if the enemies become allies
That is the only way
Well, they party hard in germ- oh wait berlin raves are like known worldwide for how crazy they are
I
Possible redemption arc I don't know I genuinely don't know how this movie is gonna swing
Another rave continuing to go
Oh
You're gonna need a little more of that to keep it up
Spine honed
Wow
Oh, come on. He's bled out a bit. He is not feeling good enough to be tossing me around like a rag doll
Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. That's my tie. That's my tie
Stop it. That's mine not yours
It's
No, whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa
What?
Wow on air.
You okay?
Oh my god, that was me to a riflin, I may jump on you, wait is that an appropriate,
can we do that convention?
Like I know they said barrel and raves are crazy, but I think this is a bit more than I expected, I think we'll be honest.
Stunny gets arrested for jumping on a riflin in public.
Well you gonna press charges? You gonna press charges because I pressed against you huh?
Let's try and end your program.
God this guy has so much HP damage. Infinite health bar.
So what's the deal?
Bruh, meh, meh. Feels like we're going against Goliath here.
Then I leave you in the hands of fate.
What? Oh proof, proof of death.
So what about our two non-alloy allies?
There's far too much clothes being worn for an actual barrel and rave.
That's all I'm gonna say, I have seen the outfits that come from these raves.
No, no, no.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I forgot to say.
Hmm?
What?
Bonjour.
Pour-tu, Madame? Pour toi, dsol pour toi, Madame.
Pour toi.
Oh, 92 just popped, let's go.
Yay, 92. Did they just get married? Something like that.
Don't try this at home folks, no definitely not.
Level 92.
You're challenged.
Winston is gonna be your nominee.
Don't remind me, Emmy.
I mean, we're at 33,000 jugs, honestly we're getting there.
We really got 45,000 or something at the start, like we're gonna be in the 20s I think.
You're welcome, LeMau.
And game, Emmy.
It's not the real Emmy.
You're peeing as my daughter, are you?
Hmm.
You're coping with a two week vacation.
Exactly, we have to deal with it.
Hmm.
Lance, who's Lance?
Winston is Lance?
Or Concierge is Lance?
Oh, yeah, yeah, Concierge is. Sorry.
Hmm.
They're fun to the bosoms, right?
There it is, one man do it.
Hmm.
What?
I'll take my odds with Baba Yaga, I'm gonna be honest.
Hmm.
Winston is happy with the terms.
Important, Meaton, Ethel Turd in the background.
I'll take those odds, yeah, I'm with you there.
Nice and fresh.
And I'm with the Triple Lusky.
Hmm.
Wait, it's a card, wait, Winston the Jewel, I thought it meant of combat, hold on a minute.
It's a game of chance of chords?
I thought it was physical combat, that's why I picked Baba Yaga.
Hmm.
What?
Oh, they're picking and whoever has the highest number gets their choice.
So is it combat?
Blades.
Pistolate.
Ooh.
Right, just paw of greed.
Oh, cause you never change right, we get it, fourth installment.
Ray, we get it, wrap it up, wrap it up, we get it, John Wick never changes, wrap it up.
This is a fourth film in a row.
Wrap it up.
Ah.
Four, why never changes?
No quarter.
Cain.
Okay.
I guess we aren't on an ally streak.
Yes.
He just wants to play Hotel Simulator, leave him be.
Not like this.
Unless, unless last minute we kill him, I don't know.
In life last minute we kill him, I don't know, I don't know, I don't know.
Oh, I don't know.
I don't know how this film's gonna end.
I originally thought we were literally going around the high table, getting all seven and going for it.
But obviously that's not how you're supposed to do it.
Pardon me.
He wants to revive Havel Hotel.
Apparently they came out with Old Havel Hotel.
And everyone was like, yeah, you see it groomed on that website?
Which is actually shot on, to be honest.
Lighting a candle for our wife, Helen.
Okay.
Um.
Kill's closed.
No.
Okay.
I urge you to reconsider.
Yeah.
I miss you too, buddy.
Goodbye, King.
Uh, level 92.
We're getting almost to 20,000 left over grapes and wine, so we're getting there.
Okay.
He says such ominous stuff.
It's almost like that old man's not written for him, even though...
Bonsoir.
Salut. Bonsoir.
Merci.
Merci. Bonsoir.
Excuse-moi.
Where is the man?
That's how he does bro.
Honestly, I feel like that old guy doesn't actually like the new kid.
Like he wants the old ways.
Bonsoir.
Salut.
Where is he?
Uh, any devours?
Nope.
He's got the glares- whoa, what's this?
The math of the city?
Uh, uh, he's wrong about that.
Okay, maybe the blind man has more cars, but John Wick wants to kill so he can keep the memory of his wife, okay?
So you're not correct, technically.
Stinky Frenchman.
P.E.U., go take a bath.
You know?
Put some odour toilet on, mate. You're absolutely giving me the book.
Are we having a battle on the Eiffel Tower? On the big Eiffel Tower?
Oh, inside the tower?
Seek and destroy?
Oh.
We are making the high table sweat, holy crap.
Hired for Gen 2 confirmed.
P.E.U., go take a bath.
That's called Psychological Warfare.
Incinerate Armour?
The movie's thrown me, I can't predict what's going to happen, it's all going to be over
in an hour, then we're going to know.
Fiberoptic internet on that thing, that thing does not hold 21 bills, I can tell you that
right now, how few words does he actually say in this plot, he's using a heartbeat sensor, cheater,
cheater, cheater, pumpkin ear, no we're taking a romantic stroll on the river, sea, was it
sea air, sorry sea air, that's the accent on,
I was a bit late for that, oh
Mr. Concierge
mm
white right
Good bye and good luck, Mr. Wick.
Mon chance.
No miss you.
I'm not going to cry.
Too frustrated.
Because I have no idea where this film is going.
But I'm not going to cry.
That was very sweet.
No no, no cry, no cry.
Wait, so how are they allowed to still go from even though he has a fight with a high table?
All fades are black.
I'm not going to cry.
I'm level 96 now, strongy.
Give me your account right now.
Just a few more levels.
Oh, they're actually thinking about shutting down the traffic because it's so bad here.
Yes, mummy, here's my account.
Stop.
Oh my god, they wanted to shut it down because the John Wick's driving.
What's that mean?
I had a drink of cola.
Wait, nice noise.
What?
Is my camp young?
Did I fart and not mute?
Hold on, what noise?
You're making me nervous.
Did I fart and not mute?
You made a funny snorty noise.
Did I fart?
Oh my god.
I did drink of cola.
You made a funny noise?
I don't even remember.
I drank cola.
Maybe it got stuck on the way down.
It wasn't a breath.
Close, close no cigar.
I didn't even know what noise I made.
If you've seen it and you've seen it and you know you want to go to Tokyo.
I can't.
Well, we're actually getting praised in real time.
Me, mommy, me, I'm the big winner.
Is this Skrillex?
And maybe my stomach making a noise because I've not eaten since the past though.
But I'm not really that hungry.
My spine.
My stomach.
Are you okay, sir?
Oh, then again, they have guns.
I wouldn't get out of the car if someone's got guns and I ran somewhere and saws.
Can't stop, won't stop.
Friend or foe, question mark.
I don't, I don't get the angle.
I think he's going to turn into a friend.
Because they don't pay him and he's pissed at his hand.
You know the classic Citroen car, I've forgotten the name of it.
Oh, it might have been my feet on the seat.
He wants the bounty so he's going to keep him alive.
There's a French saying, I actually forgot the word.
Is it bullion? No, bullion soup.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, yeah, yeah, that's right.
Walk off, walk off.
Walk off, you're fine, you're fine.
God, these movies cannot get away from like harm and animals.
Like relax.
I don't know who wrote the scripts, but y'all need to calm down.
So someone needs their like hard drive check for like some weirds going on at John Wick headquarters.
That dog literally build different for real.
It's a cyborg.
And that's why it's fine.
Oh, I like that.
That was unique.
Dude, you just shot that guy in the dick, dude.
Dude, what's wrong?
You just shot that guy in the dick.
What the fuck?
Hey, Kigtmin.
Is that you?
Any get, dude?
Oh, what's the deal?
Yeah, that was before you stabbed me in the hand weirdo.
Oh, it's backpack spiller proof!
Ehh!
Okay, that was cool.
Oh my god, it's about to background.
God, I have so much brain roll with that game right now.
Qua.
Daco.
Okay, so now he's not friend blue.
I love how he now has to use a wireless old timey phone, literally.
Oh, how else would they make the servant get their money's worth out of the servants?
BOO! Incider amul!
Wuuohhh!
Oh my god visually that's insane but I guess it highlights the pellet spread
against the shotgun.
I'm liking this like perspective as well.
This definitely feels different.
You know what, uh, Hotline Miami.
Hotline Miami, that's why.
Even the soundtrack, hold on a minute, did they just kinda go Hotline Miami this soon?
Right, no fall.
You know what I'm saying?
Okay.
What, the Doug's not hostile anymore?
The Doug's occupied, alright.
He's away for a wee snack, breaking a wee water.
The Doug's not hostile anymore.
I
like the almost commentary of a foxy they actually says oh clap trap would be crying
still playing
oh he's so so oh now hold on a minute part wait
I don't know if this is a woman moment but we've been we've been at this for a
bit we get it can we get to the location to do the plot we're kind of
quest continuously right now so our last side quest unlocked a secret ally that was
originally wanting to get us okay I understand but can we you know get to the location I get it
we're under attack but come on I was still got another half an hour that's fine because the
plot I guess is gonna pick up but yeah damn I don't know if it's a woman moment but
you know you gotta get me something to bite into other than pew pew I will admit the hotline
Miami scene was good because they did something very different but now don't get me wrong I
understand it's explaining that he's such an unstoppable force
but
and the henchmen ain't gonna perish themselves I know but I'm like come on
if you're gonna be like oh he's under a timer let's not do a billion side quest then huh
oh
Uuughh.
Killing my patience as well.
Like, I do get the emphasis that he's like such a bad un-
like, you just kinda kill him type thing.
Please, get into that. Just teleport there at this point.
Just no clip through the damn walls and stuff at this point. Please.
I am on my knees. Give me a bit more plot. Give me a bit more of a plot.
Go on, give me a plot. Yeah-
Aaaaaaah! Please! Yeah!
Awww.
Oh, for-
I am sure this is supposed to be a humorous gag, but...
I get it's supposed to be a humorous gag. It would be humorous if the scenes weren't-
had- the combat hadn't gone on for like a solid 40 minutes.
Oh, and of course he doesn't make it in time. What a surprise.
So they cheated.
weren't had the combat hadn't gone on for like a solid 40 minutes oh and of
course he doesn't make it in time what's prize
so they cheated
wait Kane isn't there either it's up but Kane
wait they're both lay on he's lay on purpose or something
yes mr. Kane thank you mr. Kane
that stunt double I hope he got paid his weight in gold for that staircase scene
because those are like so dangerous and especially with the outfit that John
Wick is assigned he's so skinny Malinky in such an outfit that the padding the
stunt double receives has to be
I am so confused where this movie is going
like aren't they about to fight each other in literally two minutes time
mmm co-op mode literally they've just swapped from single-player to co-op
and they're very odd friends indeed
I
off
Kiana raced at all his own stuns?
Is he crazy?
Oh for fuck's sake the poker table allies are all coming together.
The dog's judging him, the dog said come on he saved me.
I'm not, but he can.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I wondered why they focused.
Hi Popper.
You're one of them aren't ya?
I thought it was a girl puppy.
Oh did he just work me?
You mind?
How long it took me to get here?
That hurt.
That was my shooting hand.
You imagine a random tourist walking past being like drunk as shit, what, seeing this?
Peeler, the Peeler dog honestly.
We made it somehow, every just little.
Aw.
Ha, no way, consequences.
Hey, I like that billet detail.
More billets coming off of them.
I thought it was a girl cause she went oh good girl like way earlier.
Or she, maybe I just made that up.
Me, I'm the dog all along.
You
Everyone hates the high table.
What if we agreed to shoot each other in the shoulder and no one dies?
Wait what if we can't just ever do this shit?
Can we can't just ever do this like really quick?
Wait how many, we only have two billets.
How many guards?
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
I have hope and then nine for the bad guy cause the old man doesn't want this.
No, he missed on purpose.
They both missed on purpose.
Fuck.
Okay, give us another cheeky billet then.
Cause you only gave us one.
Thank you.
Please, Katniss, everything this.
I'm gonna go fucking way older so you can't, Katniss, everything this.
One, nine.
No.
Come on, King.
No, he can't walk steady.
Your enemy is my enemy.
Come on.
And who is him?
Come on, who is him?
Come on.
Oh man, please.
They're finishing me with the final moves.
Oh, come on.
Anyone.
He never saw.
Wait, the guards don't care.
The guards to the elder guy, I guess?
All he had to do was shoot, I guess?
That was in the rules of the marathons and...
Oh.
A still illegal move?
Can we get like an ambulance or something?
You know, should you give it a medical assistance here and there?
A few gauze if you've got it.
You know, maybe a pump of O-negative blood if anyone's got O-negative.
Yeah.
Again, you persist, Mr. Wick.
Against all odds.
Oh.
He doesn't think he's gonna make it.
Spoilers, there's a five in production, thank god.
Oh wait, no, sorry, he just means like actually take me to New York.
Sorry, sorry, forgot what country they're in.
Hold on a minute, they're in France.
Hold on a minute, didn't think that one through.
Wait.
Oh no, he does think he's dying.
Hold on, I spoke too soon, but thankfully there is John Wick 5 in production.
Okay, my apologies, not only did I ruin that, reversed it, then did it twice.
Okay, I take it back, there's a John Wick 5 coming.
But he thinks he's dying, but he can't.
There's a John Wick 5.
And if you're telling me that Osaka chick is John Wick 5, no, no, no, no.
Not at all.
Bro, you ain't passing away.
John Wick 5 is a thing.
You're not him, bro!
Absolutely rigged and dirty.
Thank God you guys spoiled. There's a whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Question mark.
For once in my life, question mark.
Huh?
Motherfucker, you said there was a five.
Hello?
That's fake, right?
What?
Whoa!
No, he's still alive.
No, he's like, hidden behind a tree, right? And he's not really dead.
You said there was a John Wick five.
I know he's buried beside his way.
You told me there was a John Wick five.
He's like behind a tree, right?
Is he not behind a tree?
Wait, whoa! Why would you do that to me?
There's no, like, after-sync credit.
There's no evidence that he actually died!
No!
Whoa!
I'm, like, laughing and crying.
He actually fucking died!
He fucking-
Wait, are you serious?
Why is he actually dead after all of that?
Wait, whoa!
No, he's gone into the credits.
I don't think there's a posting credit!
Is he dead?
Is he actually dead?
Oh, wait, there's a posting credit! What the fuck are you doing? Stop!
Skip to the end!
Skip to the end! There's a posting credit!
I'm gonna throw up! I'm gonna throw up!
There's a posting-
Wait, go-
Go to the end!
Stop!
No, I don't think Sol is in the fact that he can see his daughter again!
No!
Stop!
Why did you kill him?
No! The fucking Osaka bitch killed him! No!
Why?
No, no, no, no, no, no!
No, no, it makes it so much worse!
No!
I can't believe we're in Skip anymore!
What the fuck is this?
You told me there was a five!
I believed you!
And he doesn't get to see his daughter!
I'm fucking distraught!
How am I supposed to make way?
An edge mill!
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
I'm fine, I'm okay, I'm sweating, but what the fuck?
He actually dies!
I thought I was being so fucking cocky in this scene!
He's fine, just get him some O-negative blood, he's fine!
Oh yeah, just taking me back to New York, I can't be arsed driving the plane myself!
And then fucking Kane McGee doesn't even get to see his daughter!
Who the fuck wrote that script?
What a horrible person you are to lay waste to that!
Why would you create something like that?
Why?
Why can't we have happy endings?
Is it too much to ask for happy endings?
Do we know what's in John Wick 5?
Please tell me they fucking cloned him, and he's the first human clone, and he's still him.
And they clone his wife, and then they go on dates and stuff.
I would just watch that to be honest, they catch up and do the work and stuff together.
Nothing is known about fire, okay?
Is that a prequel?
I'm fucking cheating, hold on, I'm looking up the prequel.
I'm looking up on ID, NBM, Elemental P or whatever the fuck it is.
Oh my god, what one is it? What one's the game?
I don't know, hold on.
It's like a fucking browser source or something.
Oh, I'm gonna be sick!
I don't know, is John Wick in the fucking ID Elemental P website where it's like, oh this is who this actor is in this?
They are thinking about how to revive him, they fucking better.
Sorry, they better put a defibrillator on his corpse and dig it up and shit.
But tell me he's behind a tree right now, and they just had to do that for sure.
He actually dies.
Why the fuck did we watch that?
Why did I put that on? I thought he was, he can't be killed.
Keep in mind we just saw him collapse, he was like, well, I don't know, considering the gravestone said what he wanted the gravestone to say, like, saw us, but I'm a doubter.
I'm a doubter.
He actually dies, what the fuck.
He's not behind a tree, he's actually in a farm. That makes no sense.
The ending just teases what happens with Cain.
Oh, I don't care about Cain.
I mean, I do that he sees his daughter, but I don't have the patience to go through another movie to be like, I finally get to see my daughter.
They are keeping, yeah.
And he gets to be with his wife and Daisy.
I was being so fucking cocky because she told me there was a five that he couldn't die.
I was like, yeah, no, he can just take all the damage because it's fine, he's coming up in five.
Oh my god.
All I do is cry.
All I do is cry, these are supposed to be action pu pu movies, and I put them on because I'm like, oh, it's gonna be like Transformers, all cool and stuff, yeah, let's do that, they're so cool, yeah, action movies.
They can't even call it John Wick 5 without Big Johnny Boy being there, so he is hiding behind a tree like a fanny, honestly.
Literally, he's away grinning to himself being like, they got a wee gravestone of me.
He's actually just raising an army, clearly.
Can we watch Cool Family?
Yeah, next time we watch something, it's gonna have to be something easy.
My body's literally shaking right now because I'm so emotionally distraught after that.
And before the fifth one's a prequel, I think it's probably gonna be because, yeah, I don't see why he would be hiding behind a tree, Avengers style.
Bring him back like Robocop.
It could be him after four, it could be a prequel about his tale of how he became, that's probably the...
Because, yeah.
Because why would you show a gravestone?
And it literally had the words on it.
And fucking Big Winston said goodbye to us and shit.
Is there John Wick 5 stars and he's sitting on a bench eating a sandwich?
Literally I'd sit and watch that, so I would.
John Wick tries to get back into a regular 9-5 and he's working at Starbucks and he can't handle the rush orders.
And he doesn't understand when someone orders 12 sugar pump how much they're killing themselves with the drink.
And he gets really mad because every time someone orders a drink, that one drink alone is his one hour wage because of how bad wages are.
Mm, okay, yeah, I'd watch that.
Okay, I take solace in the fact that I can see him in a Starbucks apron right now in a little Starbucks hat, repping it with his long hair.
Mm, yeah, okay.
Copium, copium.
Counterpoint Palpatine.
That was rubbish in Star Wars, well, am I right?
Um, I'm gonna need a big old sleep after that one.
Oh, no, that's wine.
Oh my god.
I can't believe that, why would anyone write that?
Why would anyone do that?
Is the IBDM or whatever that website up for John Wick 5, if it is, can you say if the female Helen is in it?
If the female Helen is proven to be in the cast, we know it's a prequel because she isn't supposed to move.
She doesn't move in the picture, so she doesn't get credit for being Helen.
It's, here is 6am, how am I supposed to sleep?
They could do a cop out and have it be someone else's funeral.
But why, what would that do?
That's the worst point, is that he got completely pardoned and could go back to the life, well, he had in quotation marks.
But that was the whole point, he had just achieved that life and then he perished right after it.
Bro, what?
Bro, I'm going to have to play Belchow tomorrow to cheer me up, because what the fuck?
There's no official cast list yet, man, I hate that website, elementopimbdm.com or whatever it is.
It doesn't say anything about the plot or the actors.
The Continental is a series about Winston from 2023, any chance we're going to watch that?
Is this after 4? Like, the Continental has been restored?
Every time I say Continental, I think of Ice Age Continental Drift, I don't even think I've watched it, but yeah.
And we need some Gamber to cheer up my brain again.
I didn't realise he...
I think 5 is a prequel because it was so successful that they want to milk it for more pennies, which is fine, because it goes to Keanu Reeves and I'll eat him, so...
Next movie is called Ballerina with Keanu Reeves, sorry, I can't speak, but he's not the main character.
Nah, it's from before.
I'm gonna need some emotional break after that, I was not prepared for that.
Oh sorry, there's a bird literally hanging out right outside my window, oh my god.
I was so freaking cocky!
I was like so cocky.
Sorry, my voice is going...
I've got a wee bit of game audio in the background for you.
I had a feeling you'd have this reaction and none of you has warned me, you'll let me fall into the sensibility of main character can't die because...
Because there's a fifth movie coming out, no, I'm literally sweating, I'm gonna have to get a shower before I go to bed, I'm sweating that much from my emotional distraught.
Unbelievable.
No, spoiler, sorry, no, thank you for not spoiling it, but at the same time, Reflins!
Why did you not warn me how unbelievably sad John Wick is?
I don't even remember the first one being so sad.
Fucking, I'm such a cry baby, I literally just proven I'm like the cry baby out of all of us at VLOG.
I hadn't seen any of them, I never expected, is it gonna be so emotional?
Fucking, look at that!
Pew pew!
Transformers!
Like, oh so fun, let's go!
And then I've got Iron Man next, thank god, I don't have to watch that.
We're not watching anything further than Iron Man because I cry my eyes out at freaking, how you call it as well, like Marvel series.
Maybe Avengers assemble, I quite like that.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
To be fair, you said no spoilers.
I know Brian, and Broly Legend, thank you for the tip.
I know I said no spoilers and thank you for respecting it, but at the same time, oh my god,
I was watching that being so, pardon me, being so cocky, like mm, mm, yeah, yeah, there's a John Wick 5, yeah, yeah, yeah, right, wrap it up, wrap it up.
But then it didn't, like as it progressed, it didn't make any sense because he literally got pardoned by the guy.
And just...
Ugh.
I knew the first one was intensely sad, but I didn't expect that.
And I always thought John Wick was just a pew-pew, literally a bamboozled.
Would you have liked it if we had actually spoiled it?
No, if you spoiled it, it wouldn't have been the same if I knew what was coming up.
Like, literally as he walked down the flipping church, I was like, ah, he's fine, he's fine.
And then the scene fades and it says gravestone and I'm like, uh, what?
What? What? What?
Like, it doesn't make any sense.
I thank you, thank you impossible, you couldn't die made it even worse, honestly.
I was like, wait, he's literally, I don't know what, it must be a Marvel film, I'm thinking of.
There's one where they're all at a gravestone for someone, but they're not actually dead, they're like hiding behind a tree, watching over.
Which is exactly what I thought, I was like, oh, he's behind a tree, but then the camera didn't do a big wide shot pan.
I'm like, uh, hold on a minute, hold on a minute.
Uh, to be fair, it was the first time I watched the movie, okay, you're not being punished.
Oh my god, sorry, the next few movie choices, bruv, I'm gonna have to pick familiar movies that are like funny or ha ha, because bruv, bruv, I'm distraught, I am distraught, okay?
Um, so we did good, yes he also did, Hollywood rules, no dead, no body, no death, the whole blind guy stick didn't make any sense.
I have to admit, I probably would not, um, I would say the first one was my favourite, and then the second one and then the third and then the fourth is, I would, personally I would not rewatch the fourth.
No, not just because of the emotional turmoil right at the end for me, but because I didn't really, stuff felt so extended and it felt very gimmicky.
Um, I wish, perhaps, it was not like so, but it was at the end of the day.
I wish like the enemy to allies type thing came a lot faster as well.
I liked the scene when they were at the poker table in particular, and it was like, hold on a minute, we're all against this German guy and it was like, well, keep up that energy, like, keep it going.
Um, because the guy with the dog doesn't, so he clearly wanted the bounty for John Wick, one big bounty and then he's done,
but he's very clearly a skilled assassin.
So, really, what's the dealio about him not just going for like, really simple targets other than, you know, Baba Yaga himself?
Nah, I know you could say, but the money was so much for him over anything else, but like, I feel like that ally arc could have happened hell of a lot quicker.
And then Kane at the end, like, just fucking going up those 222 steps, I was like, fucking hurry up, man.
Like, there was a few scenes where I'm like, hmm, I wasn't exactly digging it.
Klaus was funny though, I am Klaus.
Yeah, I don't, I think, I think maybe, I don't know why the fighting scenes don't really seem to do it as much for me.
I felt like they just went on too long.
Now, I like when they're like, oh, look how cool he's doing this and that, but I don't know if maybe because I can't appreciate the choreography the way maybe someone else can, um, that it looks very seamy.
I think the reason why I appreciate the, um, the bird's eye view scene, so much Hotline Miami scene, if you will, was because it looked completely different.
And it gave you a perspective of like enemies from all sides and he just keeps mowing them down.
Whereas like the jump cuts and the other battle scene, battle scene, well, I guess they are battles technically, just felt like, okay, okay, we get it, we get it.
But as Baba Yaga, okay, we get it.
Wrap it up, wrap it up.
Keanu Reeves is 59?
No, he needs to stop doing his own stunts like right now.
He needs to stop doing stunts right now.
He is, he is beyond like repair.
He's probably done some serious damage during those shoots then, if that's true.
Holy crap, 59.
They were cool at first, but yeah, after the fourth one is starts to look a bit seamy.
Yes, I'm sure if like we were choreography people, we would be able to be like, ah, this tactic and this was used and that was used.
But fortunately, I do not have an eye that can appreciate that type of art, so I can only apologize through my ignorant eye that, um, it did look a bit seamy.
Well, he's dead, so he doesn't need to do any more stunts.
Thank you for rubbing that in, Reefling.
Just for you, here's the timeout.
Oh, hold on, need to open up.
Oh, for fuck's sake, I can't.
Wait, I need to close my...
Where's the heck is my wee window?
Hold on a minute.
Right, put that away because we don't need it.
Put that away because we don't need it and put that away because we don't need it.
Okay, and then I open up YouTube.
No, Mod, did you just take it?
I'm supposed to do it.
No, Mod, you ruined it.
You didn't actually ruin it, Mod, by the way, I'm just teasing.
Um, what was I saying before I got wildly distracted there?
Uh, needing to time out anyone?
Rip that one Reefling.
Mod, span that, Mod.
Mod, time out that, Mod.
What's going on?
Um, but yes.
It's a, what?
Wait a minute, is this a culture clash?
Someone says what's half-a-living.
Reeflings, what time is half-a-living?
Is this a culture clash?
Do you guys not use this freeze?
What's half-a-living?
See one.
Whoa.
Okay, hold on.
You don't say that in America.
Okay.
Half-a-living means 1130.
Like half past 11, half-a-living.
Half past 10, half-10.
Who says half-a-living?
British folk apparently.
Someone's just commented on my most recent ASMR roleplay.
They're like, what's half-a-living?
Uh, wow, I did not know that.
You learn something new every day.
Hmm.
Whee.
Yes.
Someone says, I hope Stronea isn't actually a 43 foot giant squid using a voice changer.
Well.
Half-a-living, no.
Half-of-a-living is 5.25 or something.
Wait, no.
5.5, yeah.
Sorry, we don't speak EU.
Britons are wrong.
Steady on.
Didn't we make the English language?
And by make, I mean steel parts of the French,
and then steel parts of the Germanic,
and then steel parts of the Latin.
She might be.
If Stronea's that big, imagine how,
imagine how much ink we should.
Oh, wow, we're actually about to get 29,000 on the wings.
Hmm.
5.25.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
I've just had an emotional breakdown.
Thanks to John Wick 4.
I need to know, like, right now what the heck happens.
Still a level 92.
I, um, should we try and get 93 before I go off?
Now, I know I said I was going to do an endurance stream.
I'm not even going to pretend otherwise.
I am emotionally distraught right now.
My eyes are bulging out of the skull from how hard I was just crying there.
I'm not even going to pretend like I'm a crybaby.
Yeah, but we Britbongs shorten things sometimes.
I get what you mean.
Steal this, steal that.
How about you steal back the tea we dumped a mile?
Horny horny hor.
Oh my god.
Remember that one time the Americans revolted against British taxation
by putting the D into the harbor and it worked,
which is actually pretty crazy because normally,
actually, I tell a lie, you don't normally get taught
when revolution works.
It's, um, purposely not taught that often.
Unless it's done via memes, which is why everyone finds,
ha ha, dumping tea in the harbor funny,
but it's actually a form of revolution
and you're not really, you don't get many examples of it working.
Now you don't name another example of a revolution working.
It's okay, you can rest and we'll continue tomorrow.
What a waste of good tea.
Our little cuddly seaweed.
Tenors is an endurance stream.
And hospital and hospital.
Yeah, you get, yeah, you skip the duck
because, you know, you're still at the hospital either way.
Our little cry baby.
Yeah, you can do that.
You can make me cry again.
What if I cried and then you put me on your lap
and then like pet my hair and stuff
and rocked me back and forth,
reinsuring me that John Wick was a good man.
Um, I mean, yeah, yeah, I'll do it.
Damn, no chance of getting you to watch my queer
when the promise flower blooms
then that movie will make you call your mom crying your butt.
Stop, no, I'm not touching any film that has any...
Someone said how to train your dragon
and I'm pretty sure I got a warrant.
Someone else commented as a warning being like,
do not put that on.
And I'm like, ew, okay.
I thought it was just a cute show about a dragon.
A cute movie because the first movie I did watch
where he gets the dragon
and they become friends and they can both fly
but they need each other and stuff.
Um, but yeah.
You're as beautiful as the day I lost you.
Mmm, I've seen that a lot.
I don't know what it's from, but...
But no, sorry.
I know it's from how to train your dragon
but I don't, like, I've not seen that.
Mmm, maybe it's in the second one.
I think there's three how to train your dragon.
How come how to train your dragon is nice?
I don't know, someone warned me saying
that there's something emotionally distraught in it
and I'd probably be an absolute blubber and mess.
I need to recover and do some, like, funny ha ha,
like, um, the Monty Python type stuff.
Funny ha ha, Iron Man again, it's got good music in it
and we can look at the cool weapons and stuff.
Like, I need to recover from what I've experienced today.
Cocky just...
Oh, there's a John Wick 5.
Obviously he can't perish and he perishes.
Ugh, now watch the second one.
The second movie, is it okay?
Gotta cry every time I have to train your dragon too.
Okay, so that's what's making me...
I'm getting nervous.
I'm getting shaky about that movie.
We'll come back, I wouldn't mind watching it
because it was, like, the only book I read as a child.
Um, oops.
Um...
But I need time, I need time to progress
what I've just went through.
Okay, I don't feel well.
I don't feel well.
I want to wrap myself up in a burrito.
I want to nuke myself on TikTok.
I would actually like to see more movies
slash shows that would make you cry
so that us leaflings can take care of you afterwards.
Okay, that's different.
That's different, then.
I'll allow it.
Um...
Oh, I forgot.
I'm ventriloquism right now.
I completely forgot that.
Is this still broken?
Hold on, let me close.
I don't know why it's lagging behind,
but I'll just ventriloquist.
Thank you for the tip, Anon.
Anonymous, sorry.
I need to see your full name.
Anonymous, that's right.
You want me to cry more?
I mean, shit, let's just build up
how to train your dragon tomorrow, fuck it.
You want tears?
I'll show you tears.
Usually when I'm sad or go through
is when I watch shows that are sad
and jokes I knew I was already sad.
No, I would never do that.
When I'm sad, I try my best to like...
Well, work, I guess.
I just work through everything, to be honest.
Hold on a minute.
My own secret, I've cracked my own secret.
Yes, I just work through sadness.
I don't know, this sounds a bit silly,
but I don't really have time to be emotionally upset.
I have half work to do, sorry.
Earlier when I was editing the Patreon audio,
I say it earlier, it was probably 24 hours ago,
I guess I was doing it, maybe, I don't know.
Or 12 hours?
You know what I mean.
When I was editing it, I was like...
I was getting really tired of editing,
I feel frustrated because I have all these plans
and three more VTubers have agreed to do ASMR with me
and I feel like I'm letting them down type thing.
And I was getting frustrated and I was like,
I just want to lie down and rot, basically.
But then I was like, no, the reeflings need their inking session.
Yeah, but it's funny you always work too much, I don't know.
But I felt frustrated, but then I was like,
I don't have time to be frustrated,
I need to just keep going.
Who's that guy that's condemned to push that rock up the hill
and it always falls down at the end?
A bit dramatic of a comparison,
but I'm very late.
We have finished all four movies, there's no more movies.
It's just me explaining how distraught I am.
Please do not watch the John Wick series
if you find yourself to be a crybaby like myself, okay?
If you right-click the XP circle near the mini-map
and do set up, what does that mean?
XP, show XP drops.
This? You want this?
Okay, I put it on.
I think we'll get to level 93.
Wait, why did you go away?
Is that the right thing?
If you right-click, right-click.
Set up.
Whoa, what does it mean?
Do cooking, please.
Yeah, that looks right.
And then this blue, what the fuck?
Sorry, hold on.
Hold on, I'm being Papaga.
Wait, did I just level up?
No, it didn't.
What?
Wait, people can see it.
Hold on.
Why does that not keep displaying?
Right-medium default.
Duration, perma.
Okay.
And what?
It stays up?
You stay up?
Okay, I think it stays up now.
Eh.
The reeflings need their incincision to take me out through for all.
Look, I get motivated in many ways.
Some ways are...
What the heck happened to my inventory to achieve that?
Hope you aren't getting too stressed.
No, things are like definitely coming down.
It's because I'm doing that thing where I give myself too much work at once.
That's what stressed me out.
I need to edit my Patreon audios for July.
I've not done that.
Because I've been focused on getting the girls set up with shorts now.
That's the next thing is trying to do shorts and getting them up-tick in subscribers.
Because I would love to get them play buttons at the end of the day.
I'm going to try my best.
I'm going to tell them everything that I'm doing.
And I hope for the best.
But it would be lovely to get them a play button.
Should we clip watch-alongs?
What, the part with me when I'm just crying uncontrollably?
Syphilis?
What?
Oh, Sisyphus.
Sorry.
I completely missed when you guys said the Rolling Stones guy name.
Where he shoves a stone up the hill.
I literally thought you were all seeing Syphilis and Unison at once.
And I'm like, what on earth did I see to get you guys to see that at the same time?
That was...
That was confused there.
There's GD clinics down at the left, love, honestly.
Honestly.
Wait, let me...
What do you call it, a sheebie like that?
It was a sheebie's internet that was dial-up.
It was Azura's internet.
I'm gonna try and get her moved out so I can buy her better internet.
Sort of PC.
Yeah, or PC.
Internet can keep up.
I clipped the part after the movie.
She said a really cool line.
Yeah, the leader sang into the Rolling Stones.
Mom, is it like 5 a.m.?
It is 2 p.m.
For me.
Because I run a business in Australia.
That's not even a joke.
There's no booms at the end of that.
It's like, it's a bridge, honestly.
But yes.
Remaining XP.
64.
Wait, why isn't it showing a big bar like that?
I've done that bar wrong.
Hmm.
Hold on.
I've done this wrong.
Set up.
What?
Just disable the current character.
Like...
Whoa!
I am smart.
I am so smart.
SMRT.
Is that what I was supposed to do?
Set the top line?
Oh.
I mean, does this not work?
Technically this works?
And you can see I'm like right about to get it.
7 hours of driving.
Holy shit.
I would be bored out of my mind, I think.
I'd be a menace on the road.
That works.
Yeah, close enough.
We got there in the end.
That's the main thing.
It's just showing you the next level.
Yeah, we are gonna finish 47.
I don't think there's any other...
Brian!
Oh no, I'm okay.
I just...
Why the frick is this not going out of my inventory?
No, don't worry.
I'm honestly fine.
Thank you for the tip again.
Thank you for the 5.
Broly legend.
I promise I'm okay.
I'm just a cry baby.
That's the problem.
Yes.
I should think about lunch.
I have work in one hour.
Monk guys.
I don't think there's any Villarra girl on right now.
So we'll be redirecting into someone.
I don't know who yet.
I was gonna bring my iron here and get 9-9 Kirk and Mesa.
Oops.
What does that mean?
Right, let's see if I can find someone to redirect into them.
Maybe there's a Yumi plus girl up.
They kinda do it a bit later than us.
Oh, they're playing Apex together.
That's...
Oh no, Azura's on League!
Oh, hold on, hold on.
Can someone bomb Azura's chat and ask her if she's going a bit further?
Can someone...
Any bleeding hearts want to ask if Azura is staying up a bit longer?
Get yourself some good takeout.
I actually need to boil my eggs.
I've bought eggs and then I've wasted 2.
Azura is addicted to League, sadly, yes.
It's ogre for her truly.
I've been stuck with lots of work and it doesn't help that outside of that
I've been feeling espresso-depresso.
I get you and I hope things...
Oh no, things get easier for me.
I like reset after I sleep.
Like, if I ever have the worst day of my life, I just need to sleep
and then I'll wake up and I'm like, oh, okay.
Okay, let's go again.
I'm like, okay, let me get it.
Let's see what edits I can do.
She's deep in the League minds.
Is she?
Direct into her then?
Right, hold on, let me...
Save changes.
Okay.
Right, we're almost there, oh my god.
And we're in 50, 29,000 wains.
So we're getting there.
So how many did we do today?
Like, over 10,000?
So what, that's two more endurance streams?
I just want to warn you, the odds of tomorrow's stream being changed are quite high.
Okay.
Do I think I'll be able to re...
Oh, easily.
We just need another...
Tomorrow I was going to watch my gen mate's content,
but I think I might be too emotionally upset for a longer stream.
Me.
Oh, I reset after I sleep.
Also me, I'm so emotionally upset over John Wick.
I cannot, like, have an endurance stream tomorrow.
I need to give myself a break.
Because I'm actually withering away.
What does it say?
You can make around 2.4k wains an hour if you're curious how long it'll be.
So if I've got 29, divide by 2...
Okay, let's do 20, divide by 2 instead.
Another 14 hours, so technically 2 endurance streams and then I'm good to go.
We did it.
So, Veltro then.
Possibly.
I do, I'm really, I'm thoroughly enjoying Veltro.
I want to see if I can get a win on every deck.
Whether or not we'll get it or not,
but our little trouser pants thing is just so OP.
And we're unlocking new cards as well for interesting, like, combinations and stuff coming up.
Combination.
So 11 hours if you're perfect.
No, I've got 29,000 wains.
What, 2.4k? Oh no, there's no way.
Didn't manage to drop my fire-making cake.
Cake, not cake, sorry.
Don't drop the cake, don't drop the cake, baby.
If you wanna feel free to play it, I think everyone will love it anyway.
Yeah, I think maybe the odds of me doing endurance runescape tomorrow are...
Not quite there, not quite there.
Well, not feeling like it, to be honest, not feeling like it.
Where are you, 9 million xp?
Well, I'm 7 million xp, get wrecked.
Wah.
I'm surprised there's not a faster way of doing cooking.
Is there really no faster way than wine?
Or is the burn rate too high on items?
Must be.
Mmm.
Shock and behavior.
I like hearing you play Belcher on the background, it helps me finish a bit.
What? It helps me finish it.
No, it helped me finish that bit for you yesterday.
What?
I like hearing you play Belcher on the background, it helped me finish that bit for you yesterday.
A meme? A meme?
The...
Oh, I commissioned myself pregnant, did I say that yet?
There's a faster way, but it's very quick and...
Oh, okay, okay.
Hearing her in the background will do them work.
Makes it less insufferable?
Yeah, you like that little Scotch accent?
Mmm, yes, you love this voice in your ears while you work away.
Mmm, that's right.
Do the most menial tasks while your boss makes a dollar and you make a dime
and that's why you take a fat shite on company time.
Oh, man.
No, the art bit.
Congrats on finding the game pregnant.
Thank you, it was really hard.
You know, the lights were off, there was a lot of reef lens,
there was a lot of slippery wet tentacles.
I'm going left and right, but hey, I commissioned it.
It's two weeks to get here, we'll write the script together, how outrageous.
The artist was actually a bit worried about me getting in trouble with YouTube for it,
but I'm like, I'm pretty sure YouTube doesn't ban pregnant people.
It's just me being like, oh, I can't wait to meet you little reef lens.
I'm going to be like, I've named you and you're going to be my baby boy
and I'm going to say all the exciting things that I...
I'm going to talk to you about your grandparents.
Me, Mon, Paul, I'm going to tell you that they're gamers
and I'm a gamer and I hope you might be a gamer too
and I'll show you all the fun things and I'll never be cruel about your hobbies.
I can't wait for you to share your hobbies with me.
It's now illegal to be pregnant on YouTube.
It was really hard.
What was us?
Exactly.
The baby and the father, both me for overall.
Getting pregnant, sure, but how could you be pregnant?
I think just because of how ridiculous YouTube is being right now,
they need to come out and say that your licking isn't allowed anymore
or they need to take a step back and be like,
look, women can breathe again in a three-deal
because it's getting a bit ridiculous.
You think you'll get away with that?
Well, I had a really good short made about ear licking
and I think it would...
Oh man, this is going to do numbers.
I thought it was going to do really well
but I'm too scared to upload it
because I've currently got a warning on the channel
and I'm like, hmm.
And I want to re-upload the clapping one
but like cut out the breathing section
where I breathed in the ear basically
because everything before the ten-minute mark was fine
but after the ten-minute mark, which was the inner ear breathing,
that's when they pulled it off.
They're like, that's what violated the terms of service
and I'm like, okay then.
So I might just cut off the end and re-upload it
and at a later date, like once the 90-day punishment is up.
So there's like another 80 days on the punishment.
They are not kidding around.
Three months punishment for like...
I mean, I get that they can't moderate everything all at once
because they're like, how insanely busy the website is both.
I was kind of worried about the same thing
before I posted the fan art to Twitter.
Hey, what are you trying to do?
You want to meet me cry again?
Yum.
Stop breathing, woman.
You're taking up all the MasterCard.
My favorite thing is like, I consent.
I consent and then it's a picture of MasterCard
and it's like, but do I consent or something like that?
If it works, use it as a 3K video.
Oh no.
So the next video upload is going to be a collab
and then it's going to be the 3K
and then it's going to be a collab and then it's the 4K.
I'm doing it like that because I've got a few people
waiting on content.
They've been waiting patiently for me.
And I'm taking my sweet time.
Is there someone you forgot to ask?
Yes, that's it.
The next 3K audio I think might be...
I don't know.
I've edited a burping audio, which is disgusting,
but I'm scared to upload it because I'm like,
well, I had the audacity to burp in the ear
as YouTube is going to be like,
ah, that's breathing in the mic.
Here's a strike and you can't stream for a week.
The rules are getting so arbitrary.
Arbiter.
As I said, we're playing Halo right now.
I only wanted to ease your job.
I guess you like it though.
What is it?
It's an easy job.
What is this?
Stony is going to filter her audience before we do it.
I already did it.
I think I've told you guys this plan before,
but because I'll upload ASMR role-play videos,
no one is going to watch the live stream unless it's ASMR.
Because I only do ASMR once a week.
We're naturally more of a tight-knit community,
which I prefer because I feel like I can see what I want to do.
Whereas if I had a lot of eyes on me and I'm like,
I'm not sure you guys are like,
riefling rieflings, you know?
And it makes me nervous and it makes me scared.
But, you know, all as good as the,
all as good for the Dutch people.
Get fillered, get fillered, get fillered.
And the holding it in one didn't get any flak.
Nope.
It was limited ads and I on a whim sent a judgement thing.
And they let me put ads on, please let me hold it.
And I literally say, let me hold your Pintas at one point.
And they're like, yeah, that's fine.
But me breathing in the mic is a violation of terms of service.
So they have straight up, they have updated the terms of service.
And they are not, they've not publicly said it.
And it's resulted in people's entire channels like being deleted.
Like ASMR people's channels is like the straight up deleted.
Nay, nay warning, just a,
sorry my stomach just farted if you heard that.
Nay warning, nay none.
I'm still a tight note,
but you're already getting close to the 10K subscribers.
I need to test if my iPhone can work in the bathroom then.
Because I need to do my 10K special bath stream.
Doing ASMR in the bath.
Let's turn it into a bubble bath.
You say that, but the thing I'm looking forward to the most is the hypno stuff.
It's bizarre, hypno stuff is perfectly fine on YouTube.
I'm literally gonna reprogram your brain temporarily to forget your name
and respond to refling and YouTube's like, yeah, that's fine.
But breathing in your ear every just...
Even if I'm watching it two, three times speed.
Oh my God, I must yap so fast on times three speed.
It's not even real.
It's fine, just don't breathe.
Just don't breathe.
Five hands, just don't breathe.
I love the way I don't breathe.
Yes, baby.
No matter what I need, I need breath.
Right, once this pops,
I'm redirecting into lovely jubbly
Let's see.
I'm just checking everything's fine.
Everything looks good to me.
I got some shorts coming out soon, the girly.
Which I'm excited about.
I think I've already said that, sorry.
I always repeat myself because I keep forgetting.
I don't think the algorithm really uses what a creepling is.
Just have some rest.
I think you need it though.
Okay, I'm going to sleep after this.
I'm going to get a shower because I literally was sweating so much
when I had my little cry over at John Wick.
And then I'm going to go sleep.
I'm going to wake up and I'm going to edit an audio of AC and Emmy together
and pray that they both know what whispering is.
Not naming names, but I've sent a few scripts away.
And when I send a script,
I put in big bold letters and highlight it in red
and it says, please whisper through the whole script.
And sometimes I get back soft spoken or talking.
And it's actually very common.
It's not just like the viewer who I'm collabing with.
It's like really common.
I'll put it in big letters, please whisper.
And I'm like, so this is talking.
This is soft spoken.
You can still hear the thim in my voice while I'm speaking gentler to you.
I'm whispering.
Wow!
We got 93.
But whispering is when there's no thim to your voice at all.
There's no...
Uh-huh.
Okay.
Yes, but now you know.
Okay, 93.
Wait.
Why are you like that?
Oh fuck, there's not so much.
I'll just hide it.
I messed up so much.
I'll fix it tomorrow.
Please forgive me, right?
What were we on?
93.
So, what is it?
Next level is just shy of 8 million XP.
That's quite a lot.
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm not going to lie.
Congrats, Momay.
You guys are gonna finish cooking faster than I am.
Congrats.
Now go to sleep.
Soon, soon, soon.
Like right now?
Right this side?
Okay.
Hopefully my microphone...
I'm actually gonna completely reset it tomorrow
because I don't know why it's lagging, but...
It is...
I'm just gonna ventriloquist
so my model doesn't react to my mouth at all.
Actually, I don't even think I've set up my model
to react to the microphone, which I should.
You reach your level, so now you have to change the parameter.
Exactly.
That's just how it works.
It just works.
Call me Todd Howard, because it just works.
Right.
I will actually go...
I'm gonna redirect into his work
because I don't want to waste the opportunity
in case she has had enough.
Right.
Thank you all so much for keeping me company
through my absolute distraughtness.
We're going to Night Night Cooking on this account too,
but I don't want it to be my untrimmed.
I have no idea what that means.
But good luck.
Yes.
Thank you so, so much for hanging out with me.
I appreciate it.
Thank you for anyone that joined me in world
3A free play.
I do do the 3A.
Unfortunately, I did recommend buying membership.
I didn't understand that I didn't need membership to do cooking.
That was on me.
I was being a silly Billy,
not thinking with my head and thinking with my willy.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for comforting me
during the absolute pain that is drawn wick.
Whoever said it is an action thing,
liar, distraught, cannot comprehend.
Okay.
Cannot comprehend how distraught that movie has made me.
How much did she cry?
If you want to skip her back a little bit,
feel free to listen to the moment where I realize that
John Wick 5 is most likely a prequel and not a sequel
because I was aware that John Wick 5 is a thing
and I was like ha ha ha ha ha,
but the ha ha ha ha ha part backfired horrendously.
But yes, thank you so so much.
I'm going to redirect into this error.
She's currently playing League of Legends,
so I'm sorry to expose you to that.
I don't know what's so bad about League.
I've never played it,
but I guess it's a bad game question mark
because everyone seems to complain about it question mark.
I guess it's like Apex.
Everyone's like,
I don't want to see Apex.
I don't want to see Minecraft.
And I was like, well, I jumped on Microsoft for you.
So how about you make a salt,
let me make a salt you.
That's absolutely awful.
I'm going to go to sleep.
No, I'm going to shower.
I've literally cried through all of the movies.
I think the third one, what,
maybe I peered up a little.
Was the third one the only one I didn't really greet at?
It looks like Azura's ending.
Oh, well, I'm glad I caught that.
Hold on.
Hold on, Positunes.
We need to raid into someone.
I'm going to shove you on Yumi plus.
I'm going to go ask Yumi plus.
Are you still playing Yumi?
Yumi, are you still playing?
What?
Oh, my Yumi's went offline.
I, me, is coming up.
Right.
I, me, is.
If Azura's going offline.
Yeah, she is.
Okay.
Thank you so so much for the little reeflings.
I'll see you tomorrow.
Please do not be surprised
if I'm not doing an endurance runescape tomorrow.
I will see how I feel when I wake up
because emotionally distraught as I said.
We might swap to Beltral
because I'm absolutely addicted
and I love it and I have so much fun
with you guys telling me what's up.
So thank you so, so much.
I will talk to you tomorrow.
Please look after yourself.
Please hydrate.
Please shower.
Please do not strain
when you go for a poopy
or you'll hurt your butthole
and hydrate and have more fiber
that'll help with your little poopies.
I don't know why I'm doing that.
Why am I like this?
But yes, I love you very much, reefling.
Please do look after yourself.
I will see you tomorrow
and I'm going to redirect into Amy from Yumi Plus.
As always, when I redirect into another strummer,
they are not always at the same comfortability as me.
Let's go.
Okay.
I will see you tomorrow
for most likely Balletro, okay?
I said it.
I said it, okay?
I mean, although we are actually
like what, 11 hours away?
Soon, soon.
Right.
I will see you at Giffy Givers tomorrow.
Please hydrate.
Please get snagged.
Please brush your teeth before bed
if you're going to sleep with me at the same time.
And then we'll see what happens tomorrow, okay?
Bye-bye.
Bye, reeflings.
Please look after yourself, okay?
Bye-bye.